Hey, hey, hey you guys, hey, hey! Hey you know what? That reminds me. We don't have, we have a bye but we don't really have a hi. Well, why don't we do a hi. Should we start doing that? Hello! You need an opening.
嘿，嘿，嘿，你们好，嘿，嘿！嘿，你知道吗？这让我想起了一件事。我们没有，虽然我们有“再见”（bye），但我们其实没有“嗨”（hi）。好吧，我们为什么不来个“嗨”呢？我们应该开始这么做了吗？你好！你需要一个开场。
Hello! We should start doing that. Because I'm like hello, have you seen the prices!? Hello! I can hear the listeners. Welcome to Smart List. Smart. Last.
你好！我们应该开始这么做了。因为我在想，天哪，你看到物价了吗！？你好！我能听到听众的声音。欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋》（Smart Less）。聪明。笨蛋。
Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
聪明。笨蛋。聪明。笨蛋。我的天哪。我的天哪。我的天哪。我的天哪。
I was like... Most meek laugh you can do, Will. Go ahead. Okay, Sean, meek laugh. I can't just blow your nose. We're recording. Talk about, wait, I didn't say do the most meek nose blowing you can do. You nailed it.
我当时就想……威尔，你能做出的最温柔的笑了。来吧。好的，肖恩，温柔的笑。我可不能就这么帮你擤鼻涕。我们在录音呢。聊聊，等等，我没说让你做最温柔的擤鼻涕动作。你成功拿捏了。
I sneezed right before I came out. But how about every time you have a slight cough or sneeze? How about every time you sneeze in public? Now, anybody who I'm next to, they look at you like, what's your problem? Why are you even out of the house? I'm like, well, it's just- People, they look at you like you're a war criminal.
我出来前刚打了喷嚏。不过，每次你稍微咳嗽或打喷嚏的时候怎么样？每次你在公共场合打喷嚏怎么样？现在，我旁边的人都会看着你，心想，你有什么毛病？你为什么还要出门？我想，好吧，这只是——人们看你的眼神就像看战犯一样。
I know. You're like, what the fuck? But I guess I'm guilty of that too. I know. If somebody coughs more than once, right? If they cough twice, I'm like, I give them, I try to get eye contact with them like, are you okay? Or is this something I need to worry about?
我知道。你会想，他妈的怎么回事？但我猜我也有点这样。我知道。如果有人咳嗽不止一次，对吧？如果他们咳嗽两次，我就会，我试着跟他们眼神接触，心想，你还好吧？还是说这是我需要担心的事情？
Or- I still get surprised at the people who cough and don't, especially after everything we've been through, who still just cover your mouth. That's all I ask. Yeah, or just into the shirt. I used to think into the shirt was super gross, but you know what?
或者——那些咳嗽却不，特别是经历了这一切之后，依然不捂住嘴的人，还是让我感到惊讶。我要求的就这么多。是的，或者直接对着衬衫咳。我以前觉得对着衬衫咳超级恶心，但你知道吗？
It's a nice gesture. It'll leave a spot, but it's better than getting someone sick. Well, it depends on the shirt, right? And the blood content in your cough. I mean, what do you mean a spot? I had a friend over last night that he was waiting. He was like congested and I'm like, why did you come over?
这是一个不错的举动。会留下一个印记，但总比传染别人强。嗯，这取决于衬衫，对吧？还有你咳嗽里的血量。我是说，你说的印记是什么意思？我昨晚有个朋友来家里，他一直在等。他当时鼻塞，我说，你为什么还要来？
He's like, I'm not sick. I'm not sick. Yeah. And look, you woke up blowing your nose. Well, I just had a sneeze. Was it at least worth it, Sean? You old war horse. What was his name?
他说，我没生病。我没生病。对啊。你看，你醒来就在擤鼻涕。好吧，我只是打了个喷嚏。至少这值得吗，肖恩？你这个老战马。他叫什么名字？
Scotty was out. That's stupid. What a dumb. We missed you all weekend, Sean. I know. Did you go Sunday? Yeah, we went Sunday. I didn't go Sunday because granddad pulled his back.
斯科蒂出去了。真蠢。多笨呐。整个周末我们都很想你，肖恩。我知道。你周日去了吗？对，我们周日去了。我周日没去，因为老爷子闪到腰了。
He pulled his back. Everybody was calling into question whether everybody kept going. Yeah, just pulled his back like, eh. No, it's not great. I was, I'm ashamed to say it is a golf injury. I was simply leaning over to address the ball about to swing, not even swinging.
他闪到腰了。大家都开始质疑到底是不是每个人都在坚持去。对，就是闪了腰，然后，呃。不，这可不太好。我，我很不好意思地说，这是一个高尔夫运动伤害。我当时只是弯腰去瞄准球准备挥杆，甚至还没挥呢。
And it just slid out. Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah. That's painful. But then Dionne Fanouf, our incredible friend. We love Dionne Fanouf. For NHL star gave me some of his CBD cream. I use that.
然后就闪了。对，噢，对，对。那可真要命。不过后来迪安·法努夫，我们不可思议的朋友。我们爱迪安·法努夫。作为NHL（国家冰球联盟）的明星，他给了我一些他的CBD（大麻二酚）药膏。我用了那个。
Let's plug it right now. It's a canny, right? Canny, canny ease or canny something? Get it right. Because you're now your fucking deans. Canny 1200. I think it's called canny golf. Can I, can I 1200?
咱们现在就给他打个广告。叫Canny，对吧？Canny，Canny ease还是Canny什么？说准点。因为你现在是你的混蛋院长。Canny 1200。我想它叫Canny高尔夫。Can I，Can I 1200？
Can he not pull his back out over 50? I mean. I'm going to get the right word there, the right title. And we're going to plug it properly. I mean, do you think the fact that you were just addressing the ball, obviously you're brittle and you have no nutrients in your body. Do you think that that is of concern to you?
年过五十了，他能不能别再闪到腰了？我是说。我要找出那个正确的词，正确的名称。然后我们会好好宣传一下。我是说，你觉得你当时只是在瞄准球，显然你骨质疏松，体内没有任何营养。你觉得这会让你担心吗？
Are you worried about snapping some of your limbs at any point? Because I mean, you have, you have, there's literally nothing holding you together anymore, right? It's not true. I wish I was as thin as you think I am. Or at least as thin as I should be
你有没有担心过在某个时刻折断自己的四肢？因为我是说，你身上，字面意思上已经没有任何东西能支撑你的身体了，对吧？才不是真的。我希望我能像你想象的那么瘦。或者至少应该有那么瘦，
for the lack of food. Sean, do you remember this? About a year ago, we were playing with Chuck Day and Mack Laney and those guys up there in the valley. And we sit, there's a guy on this other, on this other hole. I don't know, maybe 92, 93. And he was just, God bless him.
考虑到我缺乏食物。肖恩，你还记得这个吗？大约一年前，我们在山谷那边的球场和查克·戴、马克·兰尼他们一起打球。我们坐着，另一个洞那边有个家伙。我不知道，大概92岁，93岁吧。他当时就在那儿，上帝保佑他。
He's making his way around this guy, this old, old timer. And he shuffled up to the ball and he was leaning over and I just look over and I point and Jason just goes, that's not me, motherfucker. I go, yeah, it is, that's you. I would have thought it was you for a second. That's you now.
他在四处走动，这个老头，老资历。他拖着步子走到球前，弯下腰，我抬头看过去，一指，杰森直接就说，那可不是我，你个妈惹法克。我说，对，就是，那就是你。我有一秒钟还以为那就是你。那就是现在的你。
That's you now. Jason, you are so thin. What are you talking about? I am so not, what are you talking about? I'm sorry, but I see you. I'm sorry, but I see you. 70 pounds. You're very thin.
那就是现在的你。杰森，你太瘦了。你在说什么？我才没有，你在说什么呢？对不起，但我看得到你。对不起，但我看得到你。70磅。你非常瘦。
Yeah. No, I just don't have any muscle mass because I'm not out there. Okay. Blastin' backs and buys on Tuesdays and Thursdays. Push and wait, you fucking jargon. Why don't you? Oh yeah, lifting weight, yeah, moving weight.
对。不，我只是没有任何肌肉量，因为我没有去锻炼。好吧。周二和周四锻炼背部和二头肌。推举重物，你这些该死的专业术语。你为什么不？哦，对，举重，对，搬运重物。
There's no science that says it's good for you as you get old. Oh, hang on a second. Look it up. Yeah, you're right. By the way, here's an update on the sweaters. I talked to Alex. Wait, we're moving on to sweaters?
没有科学证明随着年龄增长这对你有好处。哦，等一下。查一下。对，你说得对。顺便说一句，这是毛衣的最新进展。我跟亚历克斯聊过了。等等，我们怎么聊到毛衣去了？
Well, remember we talked about my mom knitting sweaters for you guys? Oh yeah. And so I guess she heard- How does that get to do with pushing weight? I'm just talking about getting older because you'll hear why. And she says, okay, well, listen,
好吧，还记得我们聊过我妈妈给你们织毛衣的事吗？哦，对。所以我想她听说了——这跟推举重物有什么关系？我只是在说变老的事，因为你马上就会听到原因了。她说，好吧，听着，
she texted me out of the blue as she does, just apropos of nothing. I'm gonna need sizes and I'm gonna guess that Shawn is a little slimmer than Jason. Oh God, no. She just mixed up the names. That's all. That's all.
她突然发信息给我，就像她平时那样，没头没脑的。我需要尺码，我猜肖恩可能比杰森苗条一点。哦天哪，没有。她只是把名字搞混了。就这。就这。
No, that's all. Like Shawn looks slimmer and you're right. I mean, you are, and I will go on record saying you're very skinny and stuff, but you just, you're never gonna lose that look. You have the look. Yeah. Yeah.
不，就这。就像肖恩看起来更苗条，你是对的。我的意思是，你是，我会公开作证说你非常骨感之类的，但你就是，你永远也甩不掉那种外表。你自带那种气场。对。对。
You're so right. That's the problem. I wasn't born with a beautifully angled face like you with great bone structure and a strong superhero chin. I am doughy. I am round. I am, I came out puffy. Okay.
你说得太对了。这就是问题所在。我没有生来一张像你那样线条优美、骨相极佳且有着强烈的超级英雄下巴的脸。我是面团似的面相。我是圆脸。我，我生出来就是肿泡泡的。好吧。
No, you didn't. You didn't. You both have chiseled, good-looking faces. You don't. Damn, on camera, John. By the way, you want to talk about a chiseled, good-looking face? Here we go.
不，你才没有。你没有。你们两个都有雕刻般好看的脸。你才没有。见鬼，在镜头前，约翰。顺便说一句，你想谈谈一张雕刻般好看的脸吗？我们这就来。
Uh-oh. This is the segue of All Segway. Beautiful. Let me tell you something, guest. You better not look puffy after that intro. Check your lighting right now. Don't worry. He won't.
噢哦。这是史上最强过渡。太棒了。我告诉你，嘉宾。听了这段开场白，你最好看起来别是肿泡泡的。现在就检查一下你的灯光。别担心。他才不会。
I've never seen him look puffy and I've never seen him look bad. It's impossible for him. And he is, just, and he's maintained it for so long, which is really admirable. On top of which, the really most admirable thing about him is that how well he's maintained a career that has spanned decades.
我从来没见他看起来肿过，也从来没见他看起来糟糕过。这对他来说是不可能的。而且他一直，而且他保持这个状态这么久，这真的很令人钦佩。最重要的是，关于他最令人钦佩的一点是，他如何保持了一个延续了几十年的职业生涯。
For decades, this guy has been at the top of the list. It is unbelievable. Willem de Beau. We knew when we were kids. We were talking about an angular face. Again, again, we know him. So I can't, I gotta be really careful because I just want to get a little bit out before
几十年来，这家伙一直稳居榜首。这太难以置信了。威廉·德·博（Willem de Beau）。我们小时候就知道了。我们在讨论棱角分明的脸。又来了，又来了，我们认识他。所以我不能，我得格外小心，因为我只想在你们开始之前……
you guys start. Before you start guessing, you don't know Robert Pattinson and he doesn't want to know you. It's a triangular face. I know, but he has no interest in seeing you. But this guy, even Robert Pattinson looks up to this guy. Willem de Beau.
在你们开始瞎猜之前，你们根本不认识罗伯特·帕丁森，而他也不想认识你们。那是张三角形的脸。我知道，但他对见你们毫无兴趣。但这家伙，甚至连罗伯特·帕丁森都仰望这家伙。威廉·德·博。
This guy has done everything. He's done every, the top of the game in film and television. He's done some of the most iconic films, some of the most iconic television. He's been nominated for two Emmys, six Golden Globes, four SAG awards, which he's won two. He's starred in so many 80s classics. He was part of what was then known as the Brat Pack.
这家伙什么都做过了。他做过所有事情，处于电影和电视界的巅峰。他拍过一些最具标志性的电影，一些最具标志性的电视剧。他曾获得两次艾美奖提名，六次金球奖提名，四次美国演员工会奖提名，其中他赢了两次。他主演了无数80年代的经典作品。他是当时被称为“ brat pack（小背心帮）”的一员。
He's been in same almost bars about last night. The Outsiders, West Wing, Parks and Recreation. It's our friend, Mr. Robert Lowe. Now that is a beautiful man. Wait a minute. Why are you on set right now? He's in a cop uniform. He's got a cop uniform on.
他演过《昨夜情深》。《局外人》、《白宫风云》、《公园与游憩》。我们的朋友，罗伯·劳先生。那才叫一个标致的男人。等一下。你现在怎么在片场？他穿着警察制服。他穿着一身警察制服。
Yeah. It's a fireman's uniform. Yes. A fireman. A fireman, sorry. I told the whole crew. I said, I got to go see my boys. I got to go see my guys.
对。是一身消防员制服。对。消防员。消防员，抱歉。我告诉整个剧组。我说，我得去看看我的兄弟们。我得去看看我的伙计们。
This is so lovely. He's on the set of 9-1-1 Lone Star, which is the show that he stars in. And he produces in your fourth season, you're shooting your fifth season maybe? We are almost done with season four. Almost done with season four, unbelievable. I see clips of that show and I'm tired looking at like,
这太可爱了。他正在《紧急呼救：孤星》（9-1-1 Lone Star）的片场，这是他主演的剧集。而且你还是制片人，你们正在拍第四季，也许是在拍第五季？我们快拍完第四季了。快拍完第四季了，难以置信。我看到那个剧的剪辑片段时，我都觉得累，
I guess it looks like watching our whole episode. You rude bastard. What? Try watching a full episode, not the clips. Yeah, watch the episodes. Don't watch the clips. The clips don't help. No, no, like the promos.
我猜那感觉就像看完整集一样。你这个粗鲁的混蛋。什么？去看看完整的一集，别看剪辑片段。对，看正片。别看剪辑。剪辑没用。不，不，就像宣传片。
I mean, the promos. And I see your face and I'm like, God, Rob just finished a 15 hour day on that episode. Like, it's just looks so like sun's work. Do you sleep in olive oil, Rob? Is there a mattress that's got a zip-in olive oil pouch that you sleep in? I know, look at the best skin in the world.
我是说，宣传片。我看到你的脸，我就想，天哪，罗布在那集里刚结束了长达15小时的工作。就像，看起来太像苦工了。罗布，你是用橄榄油睡觉的吗？有没有一张床，里面塞了一个拉链式的橄榄油袋子，你就在那里面睡？我知道，看看这世上最好的皮肤。
I'm an Olympic sleeper. I think that we've talked about, I get a lot of sleep. I mean, I have shame around how much I sleep. Because it makes me seem like- So you still sleep like you're a teenager? Yes. How many hours is that? What time are you in the rack every night, Rob?
我是个奥运会级别的睡眠选手。我想我们之前讨论过，我睡眠很多。我的意思是，我对自己的睡眠时间感到羞耻。因为这让我看起来——所以你睡觉还像个青少年一样？对。那是几个小时？罗布，你每晚几点上床睡觉？
Well, today I had to be in the car at 5.15 in the morning. Now, but as you know, I live in Santa Barbara and I'm lucky enough to be driven so I can sleep in the car. So I get an extra hour and a half in the car, but I was in bed at 9.30 last night. Okay. And then you're up it.
嗯，今天我必须在早上5点15分上车。不过，如你所知，我住在圣巴巴拉，我很幸运有司机接送，所以我可以在车里睡觉。所以我能在车里多睡一个半小时，但我昨晚9点半就上床睡觉了。好吧。然后你就醒了。
So what time are you getting up for a 5.15, getting the car? 5.14. Truly. 5.14, because I don't really wanna- Now you're gonna get my typical morning questions now and I'm gonna try to keep this clean. But hang on now, why are you leaving the house without a shower or without emptying yourself?
所以为了5点15分的车，你几点起床？5点14分。真的。5点14分，因为我其实不想——现在你要问我典型的早晨问题了，我会尽量保持文明。等一下，你出门前为什么不洗个澡，或者不排空一下自己？
You're doing that in your trailer? All of that? I don't do the morning shower. I do the nighttime shower. Nice. Yeah, I get that. I do the nighttime shower. So then what do you do about your bed head then?
你在房车里做这些？所有这些？我不早上洗澡。我晚上洗澡。太棒了。对，我懂这个。我晚上洗澡。那你的起床头（睡乱的头发）怎么办？
You let the people in the makeup hair trailer do that? That's what the professionals are for. Isn't it nice if you can- Hold it, Sean. You could save yourself an hour if you don't do makeup and you do your own hair before you leave the house. How does it save me an hour?
你让化妆发型房的人去搞定？这就是专业人士存在的意义。如果你能——省省吧，肖恩。如果你不化妆，在出门前自己弄头发，你就能省下一个小时。这怎么能为我省下一个小时？
That costs me an hour. That means I have to wake up earlier. Yeah, that's true. God, that's great math. God, I'm sorry. Isn't it nice to take a shower at night? Yeah. It makes you feel like a kid.
这得花掉我一个小时。这意味着我得更早醒来。对，也是。天哪，这数学真棒。天哪，对不起。晚上洗澡不是很舒服吗？对。这让你感觉像个孩子。
I sometimes take a shower, put my pajamas on, watch TV and then you go straight to bed. Brush your teeth and go to bed. Oh, yeah. Now I look forward to going to sleep. I'm like, I'm gonna go to bed. I do love that. Yeah.
我有时洗个澡，穿上睡衣，看电视，然后直接上床睡觉。刷个牙就睡觉。哦，是的。现在我开始期待睡觉了。我会想，我要去睡觉了。我真的很喜欢那样。对。
Now, Rob, you're an incredibly talented actor. You can't get this far without being a really good actor. Did it ever bother you that like, it seems like the only people that get real good accolades as an actor are those that look like character actors. You don't. You look like a leading man.
现在，罗布，你是一个才华横溢的演员。不成为一个真正优秀的演员，你是走不到这一步的。你有没有觉得困扰，比如，似乎唯一能作为演员获得真正好赞誉的人，都是那些看起来像性格演员的人。你不是。你看起来像个男主角。
Was it ever frustrating to you that you didn't get the character roles because you were born with leading man looks? Well, first of all, thank you for saying that. And I do feel like I'm a character actor trapped in a leading man's body. Well, look at Austin Powers. You are hysterical in Austin Powers.
你有没有因为生来一副男主角的长相而没能接到性格演员的角色，从而感到过沮丧？首先，谢谢你这么说。我确实觉得自己是一个被困在男主角身体里的性格演员。好吧，看看《王牌大贱谍》。你在《王牌大贱谍》里简直滑稽透顶。
Well, thank you. It's a long list. And when I get to, you know, Johnny Depp's made a career of not, you know, he's so handsome, but he wears prosthetics and stuff. And so he gets to do these insane characters. And every time I've been able to do that, I've found it very freeing.
谢谢。这是一个很长的名单。当我得到，你知道，约翰·尼德普（应为约翰尼·德普）通过不，你知道的，他那么帅，但他总是戴着假体之类的东西，所以他得以饰演这些疯狂的角色。每当我能做到这一点时，我都觉得非常解放。
But, yeah. Let's talk about that. Because your trajectory has been, it's so hard. I mean, everybody's got their own sort of path that they have, but yours has gone through so many different areas. And I was, a lot of people have peaks and valleys. You haven't even had any valleys.
但是，是的。我们来聊聊这个。因为你的演艺轨迹，太难了。我的意思是，每个人都有自己的道路，但你经历了这么多不同的领域。而且我，很多人都有高峰和低谷。你甚至连一个低谷都没有。
It's been sort of like from peak to peak. And you've just kind of jumped. You started in, and I mentioned sort of the Brad Pack, but you started in, was the Outsiders your first big film? Was my first movie period. I mean, I... Okay, so talk about that. Talk about that process.
这有点像从一个高峰到另一个高峰。你只是一直在跨越。你出道时，我提到了“小背心帮”，但你开始时，《局外人》是你的第一部大电影吗？那是我的第一部电影。我是说……好吧，那就聊聊这个。聊聊那个过程。
How you got it and how it came about and what it was like. I mean, Jesus. I wish you guys had been, in that mix, you would have, it was an incredible thing. And all of us who went through it are bonded, we're like band of brothers, because Coppola put us through such an arduous, insane. And I think actually illegal Screen Actors Guildwise
你是怎么得到这个角色的，它是怎么发生的，以及那是什么体验。我的意思是，天哪。我真希望你们当时也在那个演员阵容里，你们会，那是一段不可思议的经历。我们所有经历过的人都紧密相连，我们就像兄弟连，因为科波拉让我们经历了一场如此艰苦、疯狂的特训。而且我认为从美国演员工会的角度来看，这实际上是非法的。
type of boot camp. Really? Went on for months, months and months and months, mixing and matching. And you'd go into this sound stage and there'd be like Mickey Rourke with roller skates on, stinking like an animal. And being treated like he was the Marlon Brando reincarnated.
那种训练营。真的吗？持续了几个月，几个月又几个月，不断地混合搭配。你会走进这个声音舞台，里面会有穿着旱冰鞋的米基·洛克，臭得像个动物。而且被当作马龙·白兰度的转世一样对待。
And then you'd have Scott Baio coming in in a limousine and telling Francis he had to get back to a show. And Francis going, what show? And he goes, happy days. And Francis going, what's that? Oh my God. And then you'd have like Ricky Schroeder and Dennis Quaid and I mean, just anybody and everybody.
然后你会看到斯科特·拜奥坐着加长林肯进来，告诉弗朗西斯他必须赶回去拍节目。弗朗西斯问，什么节目？他说，欢乐时光（Happy Days）。弗朗西斯说，那是什么？哦，我的天哪。然后你会看到瑞奇·施罗德、丹尼斯·奎德，我的意思是，形形色色的人应有尽有。
So he was doing like mixing and matching or were these like kind of forced bonding kind of chemistry reads? The forced bonding came later, but these were mix and matches with everybody present. So everybody showed up at eight o'clock in the morning and you left at seven o'clock at night and you just sat on the floor and he would go,
所以他是在做混搭，还是说这些类似于为了培养默契而进行的化学反应试镜？被迫培养默契是后来的事了，但这些是所有人都在场的混搭试镜。所以每个人早上八点出现，晚上七点离开，你就坐在地板上，他会说，
okay, I wanna see Dennis Quaid with Henry Thomas and Ricky Schroeder and whatever. Wow, that's wild. Wow. What was the name of your character again? It wasn't- Soda Pop. Soda Pop.
好的，我想看丹尼斯·奎德和亨利·托马斯、瑞奇·施罗德一起搭戏，诸如此类。哇，太疯狂了。哇。你角色的名字叫什么来着？不是——苏打绿（Soda Pop）。苏打绿。
Yes. Soda Pop. You know what's really cool about the Outsiders is every, it's part of the seventh grade curriculum. Yeah. Of almost every school in the country. So every year there's a new group of seventh graders who get introduced to not only to the Outsiders,
是的。苏打绿。《局外人》最酷的地方在于，每个人，它是全国几乎所有学校七年级课程的一部分。是的。所以每年都会有一群新的七年级学生，不仅接触到《局外人》，
but the, you know, like, Soda Pop, Curtis, yay. So that's super cool. And look at you now from Soda Pop to cop. I literally just had a guy send me a text this morning and he said, stay gold pony boy. He literally said that on a text this morning from Harry Chung, Will. Oh yeah?
还有，你知道的，比如，苏打绿，柯蒂斯，耶。所以这超级酷。看看现在的你，从苏打绿变成了警察。我刚才早上刚收到一个家伙发来的信息，他说，保持金子般的纯真，小马驹男孩（Stay gold, pony boy）。威廉，哈里·钟今天早上发的信息里真的是这么说的。哦，是吗？
Yeah. I remember when I was in the movie, I was about to lay in whoever did it, but I like Harry a lot. He's a friend. Harry's a good man. He's a good man. So-
对。我记得我拍电影的时候，我差点躺平，不管是谁干的，但我很喜欢哈里。他是我的朋友。哈里是个好人。他是个好人。所以——
I remember when you were in contact. I remember when you were in contact and it was like, that's one of my favorite movies of all time. Yeah, I love it. And I was like, and you showed up on screen. I was like, wait, that's Rob Lowe. I was like, I don't know, 22 years old when it came out, I was like, wait, Rob Lowe is in this movie.
我记得你联系的时候。我记得你联系的时候，我就觉得，那是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。对，我喜欢它。我当时想，然后你出现在屏幕上，我就想，等等，那是罗布·劳。我当时，电影上映时我大概22岁，我就想，等等，罗布·劳在这部电影里。
That's so crazy and amazing. Like, to Will's point, you would take no peaks, just all peaks, right? No valleys. And you would appear even if it was the smallest role or a leading role or whatever. There were always seams at least the perception was that they were all super high quality movies and TV shows.
这太疯狂、太神奇了。就像威尔说的，你没有低谷，只有高峰，对吧？没有低谷。而且你总会出镜，无论是最小的角色还是主角什么的。至少大家的普遍看法是，它们都是高质量的电影和电视节目。
Totally. And by the way, sometimes with Sean Robb, as you know, sometimes it's like having a kid come in because it just goes, I remember when you were in contact and you're like, okay, man, we're not just fucking doing free form, just whatever pops into our fucking head.
完全正确。顺便说一句，罗布，有时候肖恩就像你知道的那样，有时候就像有个小孩跑进来一样，因为他会说，我记得你联系的时候，你会说，好吧，伙计，我们可不是在瞎搞自由发挥，不管什么脑残想法都往外蹦。
Jesus Christ. I remember one time I saw you on a fucking what, man? Jesus. I remember. I thought you had a billboard one. It's nominated for his question asking skills. Of the three of us, he was nominated for the host of the year. Singled out.
天哪。我记得有一次我看见你在一个该死的什么上面，伙计？天哪。我记得。我还以为你有个广告牌呢。他因为提问技巧获得提名。在我们三个当中，他被提名为了年度主持人。脱颖而出。
But Rob, Rob, you don't get to singled out. Singled out of the trifecta. No, is this true? This is amazing. No, yeah. It's true. It's 100% true. The best host of a podcast.
但是罗布，罗布，你可不能脱颖而出。从这个三人组合中脱颖而出。不，这是真的吗？这太惊人了。不，是的。这是真的。100%是真的。最棒的播客主持人。
Well, there's three of us, you know? No, just Sean. Just Sean. That is the greatest thing I've ever heard. Yeah. He didn't win, okay? That's the greatest thing I've ever heard. Why?
好吧，我们有三个人，你知道吗？不，只有肖恩。只有肖恩。这是我听过最棒的事了。对。他没赢，好吧？这是我听过最棒的事了。为什么？
Missed it. Because they finally went and listened to it. And then they were like, oh, shit. Not him. But Rob, so you do like the outsiders, and it is true as Sean says, and what we were saying, which is like, you do all these things that are amazing,
错过了。因为他们最终去听了。然后他们就想，哦，操。不是他。但罗布，你确实喜欢《局外人》，就像肖恩说的，也是我们一直在说的那样，你做了所有这些令人惊叹的事情，
that each one of them have a place in, culturally, a place in everybody's lives, whether it's the outsiders, and then saying almost fire about us. Which I just saw. I just watched it for the first time ever. Are you serious? I swear to God.
它们在文化上都在每个人的生活中占据一席之地，无论是《局外人》，然后是《昨夜情深》。我刚看过。我这辈子第一次看。你是认真的吗？我发誓。
Never saw it. I watched it like a month or two ago. No, he's saying, are you serious that you're just interrupting and giving us an alert? Sorry. So you do the outsiders. What was film number two? After the outsiders, which was a big sensation,
从来没看过。我大概一个月或两个月前才看的。不，他是说，你认真的吗，你居然打断我们然后给我们一个突发消息？抱歉。所以你拍了《局外人》。第二部电影是什么？在引起巨大轰动的《局外人》之后，
and we all saw it, what was the next thing? What was the move when that came out? Was it like you had everything offered to you? All of us got a lot of offers. I mean, I think Tom did the best with it because he followed it up with Risky Business, and that was the beginning for him. I did a movie called Class with Andrew McCarthy
我们都看了，接下来是什么？当那部电影上映时，反响如何？是不是所有的角色都向你涌来？我们所有人都得到了很多邀约。我的意思是，我觉得汤姆（克鲁斯）处理得最好，因为他紧接着拍了《乖仔也疯狂》（Risky Business），那是他的起步。我拍了一部叫《油脂妹》（Class，应为《青春 Solitaire》/《Class》）的电影，合作的有安东尼·麦卡锡
and Jacqueline Bassett. Yes, you did. Oh, I know it well. Good for you, Rob. Right? Yeah, great film. Good for you, okay? Class act.
和杰奎琳·比塞特。是的，你拍了。哦，我很清楚。真为你高兴，罗布。对吧？是的，好电影。真为你高兴，好吧？名作风范。
Right? What was going on there? Okay, go ahead. No. No. Yeah, no. You don't have to admit to anything on this podcast. You just keep going with your answer.
对吧？当时情况怎么样？好吧，继续。不。不。对，不用。你不需要在这个播客里承认任何事。你继续回答你的问题。
I thought. Wait, I have something I want to say about contact after Will gets there. Holy fuck. I love that he's obsessed with contact. I had two lines in it, but it's good movie. I'm obsessed with you in it too. Obsessed, Will.
我以为。等等，在威尔说完之后，我还有话要说关于《超时空接触》（Contact）。真他妈的。我太喜欢他对《超时空接触》的痴迷了。我在里面只有两句台词，但这是部好电影。我也对你在里面的表现痴迷。痴迷，威尔。
I used it. Obsessed, and it's his favorite movie of all time. Go figure it. Hey, listen, Rob, so you do, oh god. Thanks to Star Trek. Sometimes it's like, you just got to breathe. They're right. You just do have to breathe.
我用过。痴迷，而且这是他有史以来最喜欢的电影。你瞧。嘿，听着，罗布，所以你拍了，哦天哪。多亏了《星际迷航》。有时候你就是得呼吸。他们说得对。你确实得呼吸。
Finish your juice box, Sean. So, Rob, so you do class with Andy McCarthy. Jacqueline Bassette, yep. Jacqueline Bassette, and then what was after? Then it's Sean's favorite actor, Jody Foster. Yes. Can I say something about that movie? In Hotel New Hampshire, and Hotel New Hampshire was gonna be,
喝完你的果汁盒吧，肖恩。所以，罗布，你和安迪·麦卡锡合作了《油脂妹》。杰奎琳·比塞特，对。杰奎琳·比塞特，接下来是什么？然后是肖恩最喜欢的演员，朱迪·福斯特。是的。我能谈谈那部电影吗？在《新罕布什尔旅馆》（Hotel New Hampshire）里，《新罕布什尔旅馆》将成为，
that was the one everybody, all the young actors wanted to do, because they thought it was gonna be Oscar type movie, because in those days, however you want to call them, Bratback movies, Teen movies, John Hughes movies, whatever you want to call them, they were like the guilty pleasure of the movie business. Like today they'd be straight movies.
那是每个人，所有年轻演员都想拍的电影，因为他们以为那会是一部奥斯卡级别的电影，因为在那个年代，无论你想怎么称呼它们，小背心帮电影、青少年电影、约翰·休斯电影，无论你怎么称呼它们，它们就像是电影界的罪恶快感。就像今天它们会是主流正片一样。
There'd be no guilt associated with them at all. In fact, they'd be the tent pole. But in those days, it was like, in terms of endearments, the real movie this year, okay? And, oh, you're doing that trifle over here? Like that's the way it was, that's what it was. It was very segregated in that way, but Hotel New Hampshire felt like a real movie.
里面不会有任何负罪感。事实上，它们会成为顶梁柱。但在那个年代，感觉就像是《母女情深》，这才是今年真正的电影，好吧？然后，哦，你在这儿挑三拣四的？事情就是这样，它就是那样。在这方面分得很清，但《新罕布什尔旅馆》感觉像是一部真正的电影。
Of course, then it came out the same weekend as Splash, and that was the end of it. Oh, wow. Wasn't that a John Irving book? It's a John Irving book, yeah, yeah. And it did, I remember when that came out, God, what was that like? There he goes.
当然，后来它上映的那个周末刚好碰上了《美人鱼》（Splash），然后就结束了。哦，哇。那不是约翰·欧文的书吗？那是约翰·欧文的书，对，对。确实，我记得那部电影上映的时候，天哪，那是什么时候？他来了。
85? 84, 83, 83, late 83. So, I know I messed up on that one. I'm usually a really good movie. But just inside the same decade was just incredible. That, but so you do, but you did, I know that you're sort of, you're saying that these are the films that were the trifle,
85年？84年，83年，83年，83年末。所以，我知道我那部记错了。我通常对电影很在行。但就在同一个十年里，真是不可思议。那部，所以你拍了，我知道你某种程度上，你说这些电影是微不足道的，
but these were the films that people were going to see, that all of us were going to see. You know, I mean, I wasn't a huge student of the cinema yet. And those are the movies that I wanted to go see. I wanted to go see you guys in those. I wanted to go see Youngblood, by the way, as a Canadian. Yeah, yeah. Dude, Rob, let's talk about Youngblood for a second.
但这些正是人们去看，我们所有人都要去看的电影。你知道，我的意思是，我还不是个狂热的电影专业学生。那些正是我想要去看的电影。我想去看你们演的那些。顺便说一句，作为一个加拿大人，我也想去看《冰球兄弟》（Youngblood）。对，对。老兄，罗布，我们来聊聊《冰球兄弟》。
Youngblood, I mean, on Quick Five for us? Sure. Yeah, go ahead, Rob, talk about it. Yeah, go ahead. Youngblood is, I think it might be the second best hockey movie at first is Slap Shot. Let's face it, Slap Shot's one of the greatest movies ever made, period.
《冰球兄弟》，我的意思是，给我们的快问快答？当然。对，上吧，罗布，聊聊它。对，上吧。《冰球兄弟》嘛，我觉得它可能是第二好的冰球电影，第一是《火爆群龙》（Slap Shot）。面对现实吧，《火爆群龙》是有史以来最伟大的电影之一，句号。
Mighty Ducks, Mighty Ducks, Mighty Ducks. No, I'm throwing down. I'm sorry, I'm not having it. No, I mean, I'm just not having it. I know, I'm with Rob, I'm with Rob. Now, yeah, Youngblood is fun, because whenever I get to go to a hockey game, people are super excited,
《野鸭变凤凰》（Mighty Ducks），《野鸭变凤凰》，《野鸭变凤凰》。不，我要拍桌子了。抱歉，我可不认同。不，我的意思是，我就是不认同。我知道，我站罗布这边，我站罗布这边。现在，对，《冰球兄弟》很有趣，因为每当我去看一场冰球比赛时，人们都超级兴奋，
because there aren't that many hockey movies. There aren't that many, if you're a hockey fan, there aren't all that many, really. No, dude, and we loved, as a Canadian, we loved Youngblood, and I would say this, Slap Shot maybe because it came before in Paul Newman, et cetera, but they're kind of different. They fall into different categories within hockey.
因为冰球电影没那么多。没那么多，如果你是个冰球迷，真的没那么多。不，老兄，作为加拿大人，我们超爱《冰球兄弟》，而且我要说的是，《火爆群龙》也许是因为它在保罗·纽曼之前等等，但它们有点不同。它们属于冰球题材里不同的类别。
So it's in terms of like a pure hockey movie that's not a comedy, Youngblood is the best in that regard. So they're very different. Pure hockey, pretty few young hockey player. I mean, everybody who's played hockey has worn that movie out, because it's about coming up into the league, so. Now, were you a good skater?
所以就一部不是喜剧的纯粹冰球电影而言，《冰球兄弟》在这方面是最好的。所以它们非常不同。纯粹的冰球，一个年轻的冰球运动员。我的意思是，每个打过冰球的人都把那部电影盘烂了，因为讲的是进入联盟的故事，所以。那么，你滑冰滑得好吗？
Were you playing hockey at that time? No. That was horrible. I mean, I could Rockefeller Center date, hold hands, skate. Right. And so it was the first time I ever had a trainer or I had to work at, and I,
你当时在打冰球吗？没有。那太糟糕了。我的意思是，我只会去洛克菲勒中心牵着手那种滑冰。对。所以那是我第一次有教练，或者说我必须为之努力，而且，
Swayze was my co-star, Patrick Swayze, and we trained every day for almost eight weeks, six hours a day. Brutal, brutal, brutal training, and I got to be pretty good on skates at that point. Wow, and Keanu was in it too. No, what? He was the goalie.
帕特里克·斯威兹是我的联合主演，帕特里克·斯威兹，我们连续近八周每天训练，一天六个小时。残酷，残酷，残酷的训练，那时候我的滑冰技术变得相当不错。哇，基努（里维斯）也在里面。不，什么？他是守门员。
He was the goalie. I thought he was an actual French-Canadian goalie. He was, right? We had him on the podcast. We just had him on the podcast. We didn't say that he was a goalie. He was a goalie, yeah. Yeah.
他是守门员。我以为他是个真正的法裔加拿大守门员。他是，对吧？我们把他请到了播客上。我们刚把他请到播客上。我们没说他是守门员。他是个守门员，对。对。
There you go. Someone listens. Do you remember interacting with Keanu back then and thinking like, oh, this kid's gonna do something? Like, do you have anything like that? Will, I'm telling you, and this is no slight to Keanu Reeves who I adore, I thought he was a French-Canadian goalie.
这不就对了。有人在听。你还记得当年和基努互动，然后心想，哦，这小子以后会有出息吗？你有过这种感觉吗？威尔，我告诉你，这绝对不是看低我深爱的基努·里维斯，我当时以为他是个法裔加拿大守门员。
Wow. I thought, which probably tells you all you need to know because I thought he was the real thing. That's how good he is. And we will be right back. Listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by Benjamin Moore. Now, I live in a home.
哇。我以为，这大概说明了你需要知道的一切，因为我以为他是货真价实的。他就是这么厉害。我们马上回来。听众朋友们，本期节目部分由本杰明·摩尔（Benjamin Moore）赞助播出。现在，我住在一个家里。
I have other people that live in the home with me, my wife and my two children. And what you gotta do when you are alive is eat. And someone's got to cook, and I'm the only one that raises their hand every once in a while, but I should keep it down because the cooking is terrible. What happens with the cooking
家里还有其他人跟我一起住，我的妻子和两个孩子。活着就得吃饭。总得有人做饭，而我是唯一一个偶尔会举手的人，但我还是别太张扬了，因为我做饭水平太差了。做饭的结果就是，
is that the cooking ends up getting thrown across the room and onto the wall. So what I need is a lot of white paint around. And I like to use Benjamin Moore because that's high quality white paint. You're not gonna see the pasta sauce bleed through, okay, I have issues. And so I need high quality paint, right?
做好的饭菜最后会被扔到房间各处甚至墙上。所以我需要周围有很多白漆。我喜欢用本杰明·摩尔，因为那是高质量的白漆。你不会看到意大利面酱渗透过去，好吧，我有点毛病。所以我需要高质量的漆，对吧？
Got it? We all love a beautiful home, but messes are a part of home life, especially my home life. So it's great having a high quality paint to stand up to everything from my bad cooking to kids and dogs and everything in between. Gang with Benjamin Moore's premium colors,
懂了吗？我们都喜欢美丽的家，但混乱是家庭生活的一部分，尤其是我的家庭生活。所以拥有一种能够经受住从我糟糕的厨艺到孩子、狗以及介于两者之间的一切考验的高质量油漆，真的很棒。伙计们，使用本杰明·摩尔的优质色彩，
you can see the difference. They have a whole team dedicated to ensuring best in class formulations that are better, stronger and simpler. Benjamin Moore paint is only sold at locally owned stores. Say 15% off your next paint or sample purchase at benjaminmoore.com using code SMARTLESS. That's benjaminmoore.com, code SMARTLESS.
你能看出区别。他们有一整支团队致力于确保提供更好、更强、更简单的同类最佳配方。本杰明·摩尔油漆仅在当地人经营的商店出售。使用代码 SMARTLESS 在 benjaminmoore.com 上购买下一次油漆或样品可享 15% 的折扣。网址是 benjaminmoore.com，代码 SMARTLESS。
Now there are some great things about being an adult. Am I right? Like you can have ice cream for dinner the whole week off if you really want to. Two different colored socks, just go ahead and get crazy. But then there's the other side of it, you know, adulting and the actual responsibilities that come with it, working, paying bills,
成年有一些很棒的地方。我说的对吧？比如你可以一整周都把冰淇淋当晚饭吃，如果你真想这么干的话。穿两只不同颜色的袜子，尽管去疯狂吧。但硬币的另一面是，你知道的，成年以及随之而来的实际责任，工作、付账单、
buying a home, the big stuff. There's no instruction manual for any of it. So figuring it out on your own, well, it can be stressful. Am I right, fellow adults? With State Farm, you can scratch insurance off that list. So when you ask yourself, what if my policy doesn't cover this or what if I have to make a claim in the middle of the night
买房，这些大事。所有这些都没有使用说明书。所以一切全靠自己摸索，这可能会很有压力。我说的对吗，同路的大人们？有了州立农业保险公司（State Farm），你就可以把保险从这份清单上划掉了。所以当你问自己，如果我的保单不涵盖这个怎么办，或者如果我必须在半夜索赔怎么办，
or even what if I don't know what something in my policy means? State Farm is there for your what ifs. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions because that's just what they do. It's what they do there at State Farm. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there.
甚至如果我不知道保单里的某个词是什么意思怎么办？State Farm 随时为你的“如果”保驾护航。你可以在 State Farm 移动应用上提交理赔申请，与真人对话，包括你的代理人，你可以不分昼夜地就保险范围和保单问题打电话，因为这就是他们的工作。这就是 State Farm 员工的日常。像好邻居一样，State Farm 一直在你身边。
Call or go to statefarm.com for a quote today. You're welcome. Hey, smart list listener. Did you know that we get support from Helix? Well, you do now. You know what else Helix supports? My napping addiction. So with this Helix mattress that I got,
今天就打电话或访问 statefarm.com 获取报价吧。不客气。嘿，《聪明笨蛋》的听众。你知道我们得到了 Helix 的赞助吗？现在你知道了。你知道 Helix 还赞助了什么吗？我的打盹瘾。所以有了我买的这款 Helix 床垫，
I got the Midnight Luxe mattress, so do Will Arnett. He also likes napping. I have found this is the best mattress for sleeping while the sun is up. And if you're a loser like me that can pack a lot of sleep in during work hours, let me tell you something. The Midnight Luxe will keep you unemployed as long as you want.
我买的是 Midnight Luxe 床垫，威尔·阿奈特也是。他也喜欢打盹。我发现这是太阳落山前睡觉最好的床垫。如果你像我一样是个废柴，能在工作时间狂睡一场，那我告诉你。Midnight Luxe 会让你想失业多久就失业多久。
Now that's about as great an endorsement as I can give, folks. The Helix lineup includes 14 unique mattresses, including a collection of luxury models, a mattress for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for the night. And even a mattress made just for kids. I'm imagining that smaller.
伙计们，这大概是我能给出的最高评价了。Helix 系列包括 14 种独特的床垫，包括一个奢华系列、一款适合体型高大者的床垫，甚至还有一款专门为夜猫子打造的床垫。甚至还有一款专门为儿童打造的床垫。我想象那是缩小版的。
There are models with memory foam layers to provide optimal pressure relief if you sleep on your side, or models with a more responsive foam to cradle your body for essential support in stomach and back sleeping positions. Helix has been awarded the number one mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine.
有些型号带有记忆海绵层，如果你侧睡，可以提供最佳的压力缓解；有些型号带有反应更灵敏的泡沫，可以环抱你的身体，为俯卧和仰卧姿势提供必要的支撑。Helix 被 GQ 杂志和《连线》杂志评为第一床垫之选。
Not sure what makes them experts on sleeping, but they are reputable publications and I am taking it as a positive. It's even recommended by multiple leading chiropractors and doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to solution for improving your sleep. On top of all that, you've got my personal endorsement
虽然不确定是什么让他们成了睡眠专家，但他们是权威出版物，我把它当作积极的评价。它甚至被多位顶尖脊椎指压治疗师和睡眠医学博士推荐为改善睡眠的首选解决方案。最棒的是，你得到了我的个人背书，
for how it can keep you napping while everyone else is working. Helix is offering up to 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With Helix, better sleep starts now. And now back to the show.
关于它是如何在别人都在工作时让你继续打盹的。Helix 为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单高达 20% 的折扣和两个免费枕头。访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。现在回到节目中。
Well, on the same sort of question on outsiders, was it clear to you, or if you had to bet on one of those horses to have the kind of longevity that you ended up having in your career, who'd you think was gonna be with you? Tony Boyd would be the horse I bet on. Tony Boyd is the horse I bet on.
好吧，关于《局外人》的同一个问题，你当时清楚吗，或者如果要你在那些演员中押注一个能拥有像你最终在职业生涯中达到的那种长红寿命的人，你觉得谁会跟你一起走到最后？我会押托尼·博伊德。我会押托尼·博伊德。
I mean, yeah. I mean, again, and it's funny because Tom has obviously become, you know, a legendary, legendary actor. And I'm not sure you would have back in the day, but he had such drive, such, he had an intensity that none of us have. And then Taps, I think, put him over the top, right?
我是说，是的。我的意思是，而且这很有趣，因为汤姆显然已经成了一个，你知道的，传奇般的，传奇般的演员。我不确定你当年会不会这么想，但他有那么强的进取心，那种我们都没有的强度。然后《熄灯号》（Taps），我觉得把他推向了巅峰，对吧？
Or was it? Taps was right before. Taps was before. Taps was, come on. Taps had made him, yeah. And he was so good in that move. I got it. Taps was my first Hollywood, big Hollywood premiere. That was, I remember that movie really knocking me out.
还是说？《熄灯号》在前面。《熄灯号》在之前。《熄灯号》是，拜托。《熄灯号》成就了他，对。他在那部电影里太棒了。我懂了。《熄灯号》是我的第一部好莱坞，真正的大好莱坞首映。那部电影，我记得真的把我震撼到了。
Yeah. Wait, can we go, like, go back to the beginning? Go back to contact, sure. And so on, on contact. What was Tony? No, I want it. Did it say, were you scared? Did you think the aliens were really coming? He's all hopped up on apple juice now.
是的。等等，我们能，比如说，回到开头吗？回到《超时空接触》，当然。关于《超时空接触》。托尼是啥？不，我想知道。它有没有说，你当时害怕吗？你觉得外星人真的要来了吗？他现在喝苹果汁喝得有点飘了。
Go, let him go. Do it. Well, no, well, since you brought it up at the content, but I want to know, I want to go back. Yep. Before the outsiders, but I just want to get this out about contact. My favorite line in the movie is just.
走吧，让他去吧。去吧。好吧，不，好吧，既然你提到了内容，但我还是想知道，我想回去。是的。在外地人之前，但我只是想把关于《超时空接触》这事说清楚。我在电影里最喜欢的一句台词就是。
You are the worst. Go ahead. Only person I know I get drunk on apple juice. Just swerving all over the podcast. I am dying. I can't pull over and take a nap. I can't believe you're torturing Rob like this. I want to get out my favorite line in contact,
你真是太差劲了。说吧。我唯一知道喝苹果汁能喝醉的人。在播客里各种东拉西扯。我快笑死了。我都不能靠边停下来小睡一会儿。我真不敢相信你这样折磨罗布。我想说出我在《超时空接触》中最喜欢的台词，
which was Jodi Foster and Matthew McConnay. Well, McConnay was in it. Yeah, Jodi Foster and Matthew McConnay. And I think it's like the second time they kiss in the movie. And Jodi pulls away and she's, and her first line, I'm not making this up, is I'm so confused. And that's your favorite.
朱迪·福斯特和马修·麦康纳的。好吧，麦康纳演了。对，朱迪·福斯特和马修·麦康纳。我觉得这是他们在电影里第二次接吻。然后朱迪推开他，她的第一句台词，我可没瞎编，就是“我好困惑”。而这居然是你最喜欢的。
I'm gonna go to your nomination for this year. So no, Jodi Foster's a friend and she would laugh at that. So. Fuck me. I want to go back. You're literally crying. Will is literally crying, tears of laughter. Hey Rob, you've got your own podcast.
我要去提名你今年的奖项。所以不，朱迪·福斯特是个朋友，她会拿这个开玩笑的。所以。去他的。我想回去。你简直是在哭。威尔简直是在哭，笑出了眼泪。嘿，罗布，你也有自己的播客。
You can see, it's not easy, right? It's not easy at all. You got to deal with. Fuck you. This is why I do mine alone. Exactly, if you deal with the nonsense. Thank you. No, I love you so much.
你看，这不容易吧？一点也不容易。你得应付。去你的。这就是为什么我都是一个人做播客。没错，你要应付那些无理取闹。谢谢。不，我太爱你了。
I love you too so much. So, Rob, before the outsiders, we kind of just skipped over, like I don't know anything about your like pastor. You're like, how did you get that? I'd like, wasn't that such a huge deal? What were you doing before that? Like theater or anything?
我也太爱你了。所以，罗布，在《局外人》之前，我们好像直接跳过了，就是我其实一点也不知道你的牧师。你就像是，你是怎么搞到那个的？我觉得，那难道不是一件大事吗？在那之前你在做什么？比如戏剧或者别的什么？
I was doing theater when I lived in Ohio. My family lived there. I was eight years old. And I went and saw a local school production and fell in love with the kid. Like, you know, like I was like, I want to do that. And my parents were like, yeah, sure, whatever. So you had a love for it when you were super young?
我住在俄亥俄州的时候演过戏剧。我家人当时住在那儿。我才八岁。我去看了当地学校的一部制作，然后就爱上了那个小孩。就像，你知道的，当时我就想，我也想那样做。我父母就说，行吧，随便你。所以你很小的时候就对它有了一种热爱？
Super young. It's all I ever knew exactly what I wanted to do. Wow, isn't that wild? But you couldn't pursue it in Ohio, right? Was there a move out to Los Angeles that triggered like, okay, I want to, I actually want to do this now. Well, my thing was I'm going to do, I did every sort of university.
超级小。我所知道的全部就是我 dokładnie 清楚自己想做什么。哇，是不是很疯狂？但你不能在俄亥俄州继续追求演艺事业，对吧？是不是有一次搬到洛杉矶的经历，才触发了“好吧，我想，我其实想真正做这个了”的想法？好吧，我的情况是我要去做，我参加了各种各样的大学。
There was a traveling, oh God, this thing called the Kenley Players. You got to look this up guys. It's the best. We should make a movie about this. The Kenley Players. It would be summer, professional summers. It's like waiting for Guthman, but real.
当时有个巡演的，哦天哪，有个叫肯利剧团（Kenley Players）的东西。你们一定要去查查这个，伙计们。太棒了。我们应该拍一部关于这个的电影。肯利剧团。那会是夏天，专业的夏季演出。这就像在等戈多，但却是真实的。
John Kenley was a musical theater producer, lived as a woman in Florida during part of the year. And then was John Kenley in the Midwest. And of course the Midwestern people were never the wiser. And he would get whoever's the hottest TV star and put them in Camelot or something like that. And then they would tour Dayton, Cincinnati, Akron, Columbus, Flint, Michigan.
约翰·肯利（John Kenley）是一位音乐剧制作人，一年中有段时间在佛罗里达以女装生活。然后在中西部就变成了约翰·肯利。当然中西部的人从来没察觉到。他会找当时最红的电视明星，让他们去演《卡米洛特》之类的剧。然后他们会在代顿、辛辛那提、阿克伦、哥伦布、密歇根州弗林特巡演。
And you'd like, Henry Winkler would come in and just crush for four weeks in the summer. And you'd see like Vic Tabak in Manila Mancha. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or, and it was the most delicious. Sandy Duncan is Peter Pan. Of course, yes, hot. Jason's old co-star.
然后你会看到，亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）会来，在夏天连演四周大受欢迎。你还会看到比如维克·塔巴克（Vic Tabak）演《梦幻骑士》。对，对，对。或者，最妙的是。桑迪·邓肯（Sandy Duncan）演彼得·潘。当然，是的，性感。杰森的老搭档。
Uh-huh. Oh yeah. Wait, so Rob, but that's a good point. So you're doing this thing, this touring theater thing, which it does sound amazing. And then what? What do I say in my Paul Lynn stories? Well, fucking let's go. Yeah. Look at you, you little jubblet.
嗯哼。哦，对。等等，罗布，这倒是个好点子。所以你在做这个，这个巡演戏剧，听起来确实很棒。然后呢？我在保罗·林恩（Paul Lynn）的故事里都说些什么？好吧，他妈的开始吧。是的。看看你，你这个小胖子。
Oh, that actually sounded more like Charles Nelson Riley. No, a mix of the two. This is definitely a mix of the two. One of my favorite Paul Lynn lines on Hollywood Squares was the host said, okay, for the center square, for the X, Paul, when a man falls over a boat, you yell man overboard. What do you yell when a woman falls over a boat?
哦，那听起来其实更像查尔斯·纳尔逊·赖利（Charles Nelson Riley）。不，两者的结合。这绝对是两者的结合。我在《好莱坞方块》（Hollywood Squares）里最喜欢的保罗·林恩的台词之一是主持人说，好的，关于中心方块，为了这个X，保罗，当一个男人从船上掉落时，你喊的是“落水人”。当一个女人从船上掉落时，你喊什么？
And he goes, false bait ahead. Wait, wait, how did you, where did you encounter Paul Lynn? First of all, Rob. Oh, the Kenley players. Not on Hollywood Square. Did you ever do Hollywood Squares? No, I did the 10,000, this is how long it was,
然后他说，放长线钓大鱼。等一下，等一下，你是怎么，你在哪里遇到保罗·林恩的？首先，罗布。哦，肯利剧团。不是在《好莱坞方块》。你上过《好莱坞方块》吗？没有，我上过1万美元的，这就是年代感，
how long ago it was, the $10,000 pyramid. Oh wow. Before it was 25 or 100. Yes, with Dick Clark. And that was a, that was my first trip to New York, publicity trip, and I played against Tony Danza and I eviscerated him. I once took Tony Danza deep at the Hollywood Stars night.
那是多久以前的事了，1万美元金字塔（$10,000 Pyramid）。哦，天哪。在它变成25,000或10万美元之前。是的，和迪克·克拉克（Dick Clark）一起。那是我的第一次纽约之旅，宣传之旅，我和托尼·丹扎（Tony Danza）对垒，我把他给击溃了。我有一次在好莱坞明星之夜把托尼·丹扎打得很深。
Wow, no way. Yeah, he threw a little cookie over the plate and I took it out to right center field. I love that. Yep, past the sprinting Luforigno, inside the park home run. Then they, what, you went around the bases on a gurney or what, you probably pulled something for sure.
哇，不会吧。是的，他投了一个轻轻的球过来，我把它打到了右中外野。我喜欢这个。是的，掠过了飞奔的路·费里诺（Lou Ferrigno），打出了一支场内全垒打。然后他们，什么，你是坐着医用推车绕着垒位跑的吗，还是怎么着，你肯定拉伤了什么。
At that time, I was pretty limber. You really were not 18. I love those old, the old time Dodger Hollywood stars. The first one I played in, it was such a huge thrill, it was 1979. And I stepped up to the plate and they were, now batting, Rob, load. No way.
那个时候，我身体还挺灵活的。你当时真的还不到18岁。我喜欢那些老派的，老派的道奇好莱坞明星赛。我参加的第一场比赛，那可真是太刺激了，那是1979年。我走上打击区，他们喊着，现在上场击球的是，罗布·洛。不会吧。
No way. And it was amazing. And I think I might have got a fielders choice to first base or whatever. And I was like, super, because in those days it was super competitive actually. And then at a certain point it devolved into hijinks and then you'd get Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
不会吧。太棒了。我想我可能击出了一个野手选择上垒到一垒或者别的什么。当时我感觉，超级棒，因为在那个年代，竞争其实超级激烈。然后到了一定时候，它演变成了一些恶作剧，接着你就会看到贾巴尔
pitching to Billy Barty. Right, with a huge, with a large bat. With a huge bat. That's right, yes. And that's what happened and then it all, but it was, that was my moment at the Hollywood stars. I talk to Kimmel about this sometimes, like we should approach them and ask them
投球给比利·巴蒂（Billy Barty）。没错，拿着一块巨大的球棒。拿着一块巨大的球棒。没错，是的。事情就是这样，然后一切都，但那就是我在好莱坞明星赛上的高光时刻。我有时会跟吉梅尔聊起这个，比如我们应该去找他们，问问他们
if they would be interested in us just sort of just like, let's make this thing overhand again, fast pitch, baseball, because like now I think it's like softball, they bring in a fence and we should get it back too. Listen, I'm gonna make that, if you're down. And Jason's like, how can we set the fun back out of it? You know what I mean?
是否有兴趣让我们重拾那种风格，比如重新采用过手投球、快投垒球，因为现在我觉得就像是垒球，他们还加了围栏，我们应该把它改回来。听好了，只要你愿意，我会去搞定的。而杰森的反应就像是，我们怎么才能把乐趣从里面抽离出来呢？你知道我的意思吗？
Do you ever hear, Rob? Do you ever hear about the golf trip we went on last year and Jason on our way there, there were like eight of us and Jason's like, okay, here's the deal. Everybody has to put everything out. We're gonna keep score. It's gonna be.
你听说过吗，罗布？你听说过去年我们去的那次高尔夫之旅吗，杰森在去的路上，我们大约有八个人，杰森就说，好了，情况是这样的。每个人都得把所有杆数报出来。我们要记分。会是。
And everybody's like, hey. Aggregate score over four days. And everybody's like, hey man, fucking relax. We haven't even started the trip yet. And he's already wanna take the fun out. Wait, so Rob, okay, we're jumping all over the place. But what I do wanna know is,
然后每个人都说，嘿。四天的总杆数。然后每个人都说，嘿，老兄，他妈的放松点。我们甚至还没开始旅行呢。他这就已经想把乐趣给抹杀了。等等，罗布，好吧，我们东拉西扯。但我真正想知道的是，
when was the move, because you did all these, really successful, great movies, like I pointed out before, Samo's Fire about last night, whatever it was, class, one of my favorite, Masquerade, which I loved as well. Thank you, I like that one. I thought that was a very underappreciated movie.
你是什么时候搬过去的，因为你拍了那么多真正成功、极棒的电影，就像我之前提到的，关于昨晚的《昨夜情深》（About Last Night），不管它是什么，还有《同窗之爱》（Class），我最喜欢的电影之一，还有我很喜欢的《假面舞会》（Masquerade）。谢谢，我喜欢那部。我觉得那是一部被严重低估的电影。
And then all of a sudden, you start, you made like this switch and you're like, well, I'm gonna do comedies. And all of a sudden you became a guy who was like in every comedy in the 90s, you were in them. And it was a big, was that like a, did you make a conscious decision?
然后突然之间，你开始转型，你心想，好吧，我要去演喜剧。紧接着你成了那种出现在90年代每一部喜剧里的演员，你到处都能看到你。这是一个重大的，这是一个有意识的决定吗？
Like, yeah, fuck it, I'm done with this, I'm now gonna do that. How did that happen? I'd loved, always loved comedy. And it was my first love and was obsessed with SNL. I did, for my sixth grade talent show, I did Ackroyd's Basomatic sketch. I loved, loved.
就像，是的，去他的，我不搞这个了，我接下来要演喜剧了。这到底是怎么发生的？我一直都很喜欢喜剧。那是我的初恋，我曾经对周六夜现场（SNL）痴迷不已。我在六年级的才艺秀上，表演了阿克罗伊德（Ackroyd）的Basomatic搅拌机短剧。我爱惨了，爱惨了。
Right? I know that one, Basomatic. Oh yeah, this is the thing where he sells the, Basomatic and he talks really fast and it's crazy. How many times has this happened to you? You have a bass. It wiggles off the hook. Yeah.
对吧？我知道那个，Basomatic。哦对，就是他推销那个Basomatic搅拌机，语速飞快，超级疯狂的东西。这种事发生在你身上的频率有多高？你有一条鲈鱼。它从鱼钩上挣脱了。对。
And so I hosted SNL and had a really good show and hit it off with Lauren. And I think Lauren saw something in me that nobody had really seen before, that I could really be funny. And then when they, so when they made Wayne's World into a movie. Yes.
后来我主持了SNL，节目效果非常好，跟洛恩（Lorne）也很合得来。我觉得洛恩从我身上看到了别人从未真正看到过的一点，那就是我其实很有喜剧天赋。然后当他们，当他们把《韦恩的世界》拍成电影时。是的。
I had also connected with Mike on the show. And we sort of just got each other. And so when they were making Wayne's World, they were looking for somebody who had been in a movie. I mean, Mike and Dana, literally, it was just that simple. I think Rob's been in a movie. Sean, tell Tracy who he's talking about really quickly. Oh, what, Mike Myers and Dana Carvey?
我也和迈克在节目里建立联系。我们算是挺懂彼此的。所以在筹备《韦恩的世界》时，他们正在寻找一个有过电影演出经验的人。我的意思是，迈克和达纳，字面意思，就是这么简单。我觉得罗布演过电影。肖恩，快告诉特拉西他刚才说的是谁。哦，什么，迈克·梅尔斯（Mike Myers）和达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）？
There we go. Yeah, Mike Myers and Dana Carvey. Okay. You have to use them sparingly, Rob. You know, you give them the easy ones like that and then you move forward. I know, I got some nervous. No, no, no, Sean.
这就对了。对，迈克·梅尔斯和达纳·卡维。好了。罗布，你得省着点用他们。你知道的，你给他们这种太简单的，然后你再往前推进。我知道，我有点紧张。不，不，不，肖恩。
So you do, so, yeah, of course, of course it's Wayne's World. And that makes sense that you get brought in is not only had you been in a movie, you've been in a lot of big movies and you're a movie star. So for them, it's a great get. And Lauren's like, so you're gonna, Mike's gonna write it and you're doing it, Rob,
所以你，所以，对，当然，当然就是《韦恩的世界》。你被选上也很合情合理，因为你不仅演过电影，还演过很多大制作电影，你是个电影明星。所以对他们来说，这是个极好的收获。洛恩就说，所以你会，迈克会写剧本，你来演，罗布，
and you start tomorrow and you've already said yes and here's your wardrobe and you've said yes and let's go into action. I just, by the way, Will, I just walked with him last week. I hadn't had a good, Lauren Michaels, walked through Beverly Hills in a long time and there were so many great quotes. I really, really, really,
你明天就开始，而且你已经答应了，这是你的戏服，你也答应了，让我们开拍吧。顺便说一句，威尔，我上周刚跟他一起散步。我好久没跟洛恩·迈克尔斯在比佛利山庄好好散过步了，有好多棒极了的名言。我真的，真的，真的，
and we have to do a coffee table book. We have to of Lauren quotes. It's, they're the best. One of my favorite, and I love Lauren, I haven't done the walk with him in a few years now, any of the walks. I've done the beach walk. I've done, obviously, the Beverly Hills
我们必须出一本咖啡桌读物。我们得出一本洛恩名言录。这简直是，太棒了。我最喜欢的之一，我也很爱洛恩，我这几年没跟他一起散过步了，不管是哪种散步。我走过海滩散步。当然，我也走过比佛利山庄
flats walk many times. But this is a known thing, that he walks with people? Yeah, like John Sykes said to me the other day, I just did a walk with Lauren and then I saw him with gold. I see he in Goldwyn every time he's in town, John Goldwyn. But I said, he one time, we were talking about the South and he just goes, it's a Mason Dixon line thing. And I was like, oh, I'm sorry, I'm fucking loved.
平地散步很多次了。但这算是个公开的秘密，他喜欢跟人一起散步？对，就像约翰·赛克斯（John Sykes）前几天对我说的那样，我刚跟洛恩散完步，然后我在戈德温（Goldwyn）看到他。每次他在城里我都会在戈德温看到他，约翰·戈德温。但我说，他有一次，我们聊到南方，他直接来了一句，这是梅森-迪克森线（Mason-Dixon line）的事。当时我就想，哦，不好意思，我他妈太爱了。
But Rob, what you did with that comedy turn though, that I sort of felt was, it was just, I just thought it was really admirable that you were doing this, if I remember correctly, at a time when people really were still kind of taking themselves pretty seriously and you were not. And you were assigned a lane too.
但罗布，你对于喜剧的这种转变，让我觉得，我当时觉得这真的令人钦佩，如果我没记错的话，当时人们其实还把自己看得挺严肃的，而你却没有。而且你当时也选定了一条戏路。
Yeah, and you said, yeah, you know what? I'm not gonna bust out of that lane for a lane of, I am a character actor and I'm doing Shakespeare now. He actually went the opposite direction. He said, I'm actually going to kind of make fun of myself a little bit here and just pull my pants down a little bit
对，而你说，好吧，你知道吗？我才不从那条戏路里跳出来去演什么我是个性格演员现在在演莎士比亚呢。他实际上走了相反的方向。他说，其实我打算在这里稍微自嘲一下，把裤子往下脱一点点，
and kind of not be quite as gorgeous. It was pretty cool. Yeah, really cool. Well, thanks. I mean, I love it and I still love, you guys know, there's nothing, look, I'm talking to a bunch of guys who get to do, get to play in both pools
别表现得那么光芒四射。这挺酷的。是的，真的很酷。谢谢。我的意思是，我很喜欢，而且我依然喜欢，你们知道的，没有什么，听着，我在跟一群能在两个领域游刃有余的家伙们对话，
and to do, like to be doing Lone Star now and then the show, which is now on Netflix, Unstable with my son, Hard Combat. Oh yeah, you told me about that. That's the fun of it, because they're so different. But when I first got into comedy, when I first got into humor,
既能演现在的《边境之城》（Lone Star），然后又是现在正在网飞（Netflix）播出的剧《同盟与前妻》（Unstable），跟我儿子约翰·欧文（John Owen）一起。哦对，你跟我提过那个。那才有意思，因为它们反差太大了。但当我刚开始涉足喜剧，当我刚开始涉足幽默时，
you know, when I first decided it was, no one else was in that lane, for sure. No one knew. And also SNL was a thing where like people, like now everybody wants to do it, does it, doesn't think about it. But in those days, like, ooh, you better be careful.
你知道的，当我最初决定这么做时，确实没有人走那条路。没人懂。而且SNL当时也是那种节目，人们，就像现在每个人都想去演，都会去演，根本不假思索。但在那个年代，就像，哦，你最好小心点。
Ooh, I don't know. Like there was all that shit going on. I was like, be careful of what? Right, yeah. But you do Wayne's World, you do Tommy Boy, you do Austin Powers, and then you jump back and you start doing things like, you do a bunch of serious dramas,
哦，我不知道。当时有各种各样的破事。我就想，小心什么？没错，是的。但你拍了《韦恩的世界》，你拍了《汤米·博伊》（Tommy Boy），你拍了《王牌大贱谍》（Austin Powers），然后你又跳回来开始尝试，你拍了一堆严肃剧情片，
you do Brothers and Sisters. West Wing? Well, I was gonna say West Wing, sorry, West Wing first, I was getting to West Wing, but West Wing first, which was a phenomenal show, then Brothers and Sisters with Robbie Bates,
你拍了《兄弟姐妹》（Brothers and Sisters）。《白宫群英》（West Wing）？好吧，我本来想说《白宫群英》，抱歉，先说《白宫群英》，我正要说到《白宫群英》，但先说《白宫群英》，那是一部现象级的剧，然后是和罗比·贝茨（Robbie Bates）合作的《兄弟姐妹》，
then you go and you make the jump, and then you start doing, I remember the day that Amy's like, I think Rob Lowe's gonna do Parks and Rec, and I was like, what? That's amazing. And all of a sudden, like, you're on a serious drama,
然后你再次华丽转身，然后你开始，我记得埃米说的那天，我觉得罗布·洛要演《公园与游憩》（Parks and Rec），当时我的反应是，什么？太棒了。突然之间，你上一秒还在演严肃剧情片，
and then the next year you're on a sitcom, and you're on a full-fledged comedy. Yeah, you're an agent's dream. Yeah, very few people get that kind of leeway and can pull it off, and nobody, and there's no part of you that's like, well, he can't do that,
然后第二年你就去演情景喜剧了，演了一部货真价实的喜剧。是的，你是经纪人的梦想。是的，极少有人能有这种回旋余地并能驾驭得好，而且没有人，你身上不会有那种让人觉得“哦，他演不了这个”的感觉，大家的反应都是“噢，对，好吧，那是罗布·洛，对，罗布能演”。这他妈太酷了，老兄。我的意思是，你某种程度上，尽管你觉得自己是个被困在男主角身体里的性格演员，但你还是按自己的想法去做了，
you're like, yeah, well, yeah, it's Rob Lowe, yeah, Rob can do it. Like, that's fucking rad, dude. I mean, you kind of, so for as much as you feel like you're like a lead, you know, a character actor trapped inside a leading man's body, you did what you wanted to do anyway,
我觉得这简直酷毙了。而且现在还在这样做。而且还在继续做。是的。这太酷了。然后你现在还和约翰一起拍这部剧，他是个很棒的小伙子，我也稍微了解他一点。
which I think is super fucking cool. And still are doing it. And they're still doing it. Yeah. It's pretty rad. And then now you're doing this show with Johnny, who's a great kid, whom I know a little bit.
是的，你签约了，对吧。我的天哪。太酷了。我记得你跟我说过这个。聊聊这个吧，老兄。这真的，我的意思是，能和我的儿子一起工作，
Yeah, you're signed down, yeah. I mean, Jesus Christ. That's so cool. I remember you saying it, telling me. Talk about this, dude. It's so, it's, I mean, to be able to work with my son,
这一切都始于他在社交媒体上各种“钓鱼”我、整蛊我，简直是残酷虐待。我的意思是，毫不留情，没有任何别的目的，纯粹就是为了好玩。然后人们开始注意到了。事情发展到后来，如果我出去做
I mean, it all started with him sort of trolling me on social media, like just brutalizing me. I mean, mercilessly, just for nothing other than to just do it. And people started to notice. And it got to the point that if I was out doing
采访来宣传什么东西，不管是《今日秀》还是《艾伦秀》，不管是什么节目，他们唯一真正想聊的都是：你儿子可太喜欢取笑你了。我们这里收集了他的一些高光时刻。当时的反应简直是：我的天哪。
an interview to promote something, whether it was, you know, the Today show or the Ellen show, it didn't matter what the venue was, all they really wanted to talk about was, your son just loves to make fun of you. And we have some of his greatest hits here. And we were like, Jesus Christ.
所以事情发展到最后，我们俩都觉得，大家真的挺喜欢这个的。我在想，这里面是不是有什么搞头？因为我的意思是，字面意思，观众都在说：我们就要这个，我们要看更多这个。
So it got to the point where I, we both were like, people really like this. I wonder is there, is there some there there? Cause I mean, literally the audience is saying, we want this, we want more of this.
于是我们开始琢磨这到底能拍成什么样。我们想，好吧，我们不拍真人秀。我也不想去演一个夸张版的自我，因为拉里·大卫（Larry David）把这个已经演到极致了，感觉有点老套了。那到底该拍什么？
So we tried to figure out what it would be. And we're like, well, we're not going to do a reality show. And I don't want to do that thing of playing a heightened version of me because Larry David did it so well, it feels kind of done. So what is it?
所以我们，我们把它提炼出来，核心其实就是一个拥有大爱、自恋到不行的夸张老爸，他可能对现实世界的认知并不如他想象的那那般清醒，而整个世界都在为他鼓掌，
So we, we've distilled it down to really what it is, is like a larger than life, benevolent narcissist dad, who may or may not be as in touch with the real world as he would like to think. And, and the world just applauds him
还有一个儿子，反应则是：我的天呐，真的假的？于是，我们打造了这部名为《同盟与前妻》（Unstable）的剧。我饰演一个，（你知道的）几乎就像是一个埃隆·马斯克式的科技天才，他顺风顺水的时候脑子都有点不太正常，
and the son who's just like, oh my God, really? And, and so we, we built this show called Unstable. And I play, I play a, you know, like an almost like an Elon Musk tech genius who's unstable on his best days
说不定在其他时候直接就是个疯子，而约翰·欧文饰演这个儿子，是唯一一个敢对权威说真话的人。这剧真的超级好玩。顺便说一句，剧名叫《同盟与前妻》。没错。没错。现在正在网飞上播。在网飞上，因为它是流媒体。
and maybe insane in his others and John Owen is this, the son who can, is the only one who can speak truth to power. It's, it's super fun. It's called Unstable, by the way. Yes. Yes. It's on Netflix now. It's on Netflix because it's streaming.
点一下就行。哇。说吧，约翰。不，我只是想说，我对《汤米·博伊》太熟悉了，而且我超级喜欢你在里面的表演，虽然你在里面演什么都好，但我就是特别喜欢那部电影。我觉得那部电影深受那么多人的喜爱。
Click it. Wow. Go ahead, John. No, I was just going to say that's, I know Tommy Boy so well and I'm such a fan of you in it as everything, but I just love that movie. I think that movie is so beloved by so many people.
你们是不是觉得，顺便说一句，太棒了。抱歉，当，当两个人同时开始说话，然后其中一个人说“不，不，你先说”时，我总是忍不住想说“哦不，我刚才正要说……”，而且我明明告诉自己不要说。但没关系。但是，但是，你们俩，就像你刚才说的。这真的，完全忍不住想说。哦不，我刚才正要说，对吧？是的，就好像你必须说出来以示回应。
Are you guys like, It's amazing, by the way. Sorry, when, when two people start talking at the same time and then somebody goes, no, no, you go ahead. I can't help but say, oh no, I was just going to say,
但这就好象，这就好象旁边的人打哈欠时你也跟着打哈欠一样。你根本控制不住。总之，你继续。是的。我刚才只是想说，《汤米·博伊》是一部这样的电影，就像《韦恩的世界》一样，
like I can't stop myself from saying it and I tell myself not to say it. But that's okay. But, but, but you too, like you just said it. It's, it's impossible not to say. Oh no, I was just going to say, right? Yeah, it's like you have to say it as an acknowledgement.
我们当时觉得可能会反响不错。《王牌大贱谍》也有那种特质。而《汤米·博伊》是那部我们从没料到能取得如此成功的电影。这一切始于打网球，当时我和洛恩在打网球。我永远忘不了。洛恩、伯尼·布里斯斯坦（Bernie Brillstein）、我自己、约翰·戈德温在打双打。
But it's like, it's like yawning when someone else yawns next to you. You can't help it. Anyway, go ahead. Yeah. I was just going to say, Tommy Boy is a movie where, like Wayne's World,
完美。洛恩说，你知道的，我觉得你和法利（Farley）演兄弟挺有搞头的。真的吗？我说，哇，那太棒了。然后我就再也没听到过任何关于这事的消息了。接着，你知道的，大概六个月后，
we thought might do, do well. And Austin Powers had that thing. Tommy Boy, we no one ever expected that movie ever to do. And that started with playing tennis was playing tennis with Lauren. I'll never forget it. Lauren, Bernie Brillstein, myself, John Goldblum playing doubles.
《汤米·博伊》就演变成了现在的样子。但是，我觉得没有人预料到，而且这也是那部，（我刚刚跟谁聊过起来着？哦，乔纳·希尔。对。）乔纳·希尔，说真的，他会告诉你他在世界上最喜欢的电影
Perfect. And Lauren's saying, you know, I think there's something with you and Farley playing brothers. Really? And I was like, wow, that'd be great. And I never heard another thing about it. And then, you know, whatever six months later,
就是《汤米·博伊》。是的。我大概也差不多。排在《好家伙》前面，排在《教父》前面，我跟你说，就是《汤米·博伊》。这太疯狂了。不，它是有史以来最伟大的喜剧之一。我的意思是，它绝对名列影史经典之列。
Tommy Boy morphs into what, what it is. But, but I don't think anybody thought, and that's the one that I do think has, you know, who did I just talk to? Oh, Jonah Hill. Yeah. Jonah Hill, and I'm not kidding, will tell you that his favorite movie in the world
不，克里斯（Chris）在镜头外是不是也像在镜头前一样让你笑个不停？确实如此。而且刚才你发出那种温和的笑声时，我还以为你在模仿法利。杰森，模仿一下你那种温和的笑，因为那简直就是法利的笑。那就是法利的笑。
is Tommy Boy. Yeah. I'd be pretty close to that. Over Goodfellas, Over the Godvies, I'm telling you, Tommy Boy. It's insane. No, it's one of the greatest comedies of all time. I mean, it's right up there with all of the classics.
他把我逗乐了。我的意思是，克里斯·法利和威尔·法瑞尔，世上再也没有比这两个家伙更搞笑的人了。我懂。对我来说。没有别人。永远没有。我们马上回来。
No, did Chris make you laugh as much offset as, as on camera? He did. And when you were doing your meek laugh, I thought you were doing Farley. Do your meek laugh, Jason, because it literally is Farley's laugh. That's Farley's laugh.
SmartLess由BetterHelp为您赞助。了解自我可能是一个终身的过程，尤其是因为我们一直在成长和改变。我的意思是，就在昨晚，我的指甲和头发都长了，好吧？这只是两个简单的例子。心理咨询的全部意义在于加深你的自我意识和理解，因为有时我们并不知道
He killed me. I mean, Chris Farley and Will Farrell, there's just, there's no one funnier than those two guys. I know. To me. No one. Ever. We'll be right back.
自己想要什么，或者为什么会有那样的反应，直到我们把事情拿出来聊透。BetterHelp为你匹配一位持有执照的心理治疗师，无论你在哪里，都能带你开启这段自我发现之旅。这对我这种总是四处奔波的家伙来说非常重要，我有时躲避警察，有时躲避责任，
SmartLess is brought to you by BetterHelp. Getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing and changing. I mean, just last night alone, my fingernails grew and my hair grew, okay? For just two brief examples. Therapy is all about deepening yourself awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know
或者我到处奔波只为了赚钱，你知道的，去外地工作。我的意思是，为了生活我什么都愿意做，伙计们。所以我只是随身带着笔记本电脑和手机，这两样设备中的任何一个都能让我联系到能帮我解答那些关于自己的疑问的人。比如我为什么要逃避压力？
what we want or why we react the way that we do until we talk through things. BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. And that's important for a fellow like me that's always on the run, either from police or responsibilities
或者我为什么一遇到压力就拉肚子？总之，如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线进行，旨在为你提供便捷、灵活且适合你日程的安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持有执照的治疗师匹配。而且，你知道的，你还可以随时更换治疗师
or I'm running around trying to get paid, you know, working out of town. I mean, I'll do what it takes, guys. And so I just take my laptop with me and my phone and either one of those devices can hook me up to somebody who can help me out with some of the questions that I have about myself. Why do I run from stress?
且无需支付额外费用。可能你只是和你的倾诉对象合不来，你知道的？我喜欢把他们称为倾诉伙伴。通过BetterHelp探索你的潜能。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartlist，你的第一个月即可享受九折优惠。网址是BetterHelp。我知道你需要关于“帮助”这个词的帮助，
Or why do I get the runs from stress? Anyway, if you're thinking about starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist. And then, you know, you can also switch therapist
所以我来为你拼写一下，H-E-L-P。网址是BetterHelp，也就是H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartlist。嘿，听众朋友们，我们得到了Topgolf的大力支持。我知道听起来我像是在吹牛，但我只是在陈述事实。还有这些：它是高尔夫，又不是高尔夫，它是Topgolf。球杆、球、球梯、草皮、捡球的
at any time for no additional charge. You just might not be jiving with your talker, you know? That's what I like to call them, fellow talkers. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today and get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp. I know you need help with this word help,
高尔夫球车，应有尽有。但你还能享受到劲爆的音乐、巨型球道上的巨型靶子、巨型电视，以及手工制作的美食和饮品菜单。把这些统统汇聚在一个屋檐下，你就拥有了一段绝佳的时光。所以，这是我们对你的正式邀请，带上家人、几位朋友或一些同事，
so I'm gonna spell it for you, H-E-L-P. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash smartlist. Hey listener, we get support from Topgolf. I know it sounds like I'm bragging, but I'm just telling you the facts. Here's more. It's golf, it's not golf, it's Topgolf. Clubs, balls, tees, turf, a ball picker,
一起来打几杆吧。我也能带上兄弟们去体验那种同样的快乐。我的意思是，也许对他们也管用，尽管我还没找到一个像我一样在高尔夫球场上这么刻苦的人。我还得提高我的击球节奏。Topgolf在这方面也能帮上忙。
upper cart thing, it's all there. But you also get loud music, giant targets in the giant fairway, giant TVs, and a handcrafted food and beverage menu. Put all these things under one roof and you got yourself a good time. So consider this your formal invitation to grab the fam a few friends or some coworkers
每个人都能在Topgolf玩得很开心，哪怕根本不会挥杆。这是唯一一个你可以一边玩一边再点一杯的地方，或者，听懂了吗？切球失误时顺便去买块披萨吃，懂我意思吧？另外，你既能享受户外的全部乐趣，又能拥有室内的舒适体验，冬天有舒适的加热打位，
and come play around. And I can bring buddies along too to have that same sort of experience. I mean, maybe it'll work for them too, although I have not yet found one person that is as much of a grinder as I am with golf. I got to work on my speed of play. Topgolf helps with that too.
夏天有凉爽的降温打位。现在，我不知道之前有没有用这个烦到你，但我其实是个相当狂热的高尔夫球手，好吧？我喜欢去球场。每次我出门打球，我都觉得我要创下个人最低杆数纪录。所以我绝对是场上的拼命三郎。不过，当我去了Topgolf之后，
Everyone can play Topgolf, even if no one can swing a club. It's the only place you can play around and then order another or, get it, hit a slice, then grab a slice, get it again. Plus you'll get all the fun of outside but with the comforts of inside, comfy, heated bays in the winter
那是一种完全不同的体验。我不用为18个洞的成绩而感到压力。我只是尝试把球漂亮地击向靶子。我和朋友们在一起玩得很开心。所以它实际上还帮到了我的球技。那种感觉真的很不一样，当你不再因为担心这一洞的成绩而浑身紧绷时，击球的感觉完全不同，
and cooled bays in the summer. Now, I don't know if I've bored you with this before but I'm a fairly passionate golfer, okay? I like to go out there. Every time I go out and play, I think I'm gonna shoot my record low round. So I'm a real grinder out there. Now, when I went to Topgolf,
你知道我的意思吗？我想你懂我的意思。这就是我的体验。去看看吧。你一定会爱上它的。访问topgolf.com/smartlist预定打位，一起来打几杆吧。再次重申，网址是topgolf.com/smartlist。
it's a different kind of experience. I'm not stressing about my score on 18 holes. I'm just trying to hit quality shots to targets. I'm having fun with friends. So it actually helped my game. Like, it feels different to hit the ball when you're not all bound up because you're worried about your score on the hole.
感谢allbirds对我们的支持。大自然最棒的一点在于，大自然天然优于人工加工。我能这么说吗？这算是有争议的话题吗？我觉得不算。我们都想要天然的东西，因为天然的就是最好的。
You know what I mean? I think you know what I mean. So that was my experience. Go check it out. You're gonna love it. Visit topgolf.com slash smartlist to book a bay and come play around. Again, that is topgolf.com slash smartlist.
而谈到品质和精益求精，大自然母亲最懂行。你可以将这个理念付诸实践，穿上allbirds的羊毛漫步鞋（Wool Runners）尽情去奔跑吧。是的。今年，用采用优质超自然材料制作、舒适且耐用的羊毛漫步鞋替换你的合成鞋履，
Our thanks to all birds for their support. Thing about nature is, nature is better than processed. Can I say that? Is that controversial? I don't think it is. We all want stuff that's natural because natural is better.
这样你就能一直跑到天涯海角或者只是去趟超市。我穿的是羊毛漫步鞋的中帮款，简直绝了。我基本上每天都穿。我什么衣服都搭配它。我穿它去跑腿办事，去开会时也穿，在家的时候也穿。
And when it comes to quality and better, mother nature knows best. And you can take that idea and run with it with wool runners from all birds. Yeah. This year, trade your synthetic footwear for wool runners crafted with premium supernatural materials that are comfy and durable
我有一双非常漂亮的深蓝色款，配着白色的鞋底。看起来既时髦又简约。而且舒服得难以置信。它们真的非常非常轻。能完美贴合你的脚型。羊毛漫步鞋采用优质超自然材料制造，对环境的影响极低。
so you can run to the ends of the earth or the store. I wear the wool runner missiles and they are unbelievable. I just wear them every day. I wear them with everything. And I wear them to when I'm running errands or I wear them if I'm going to meetings, I wear them when I'm at home.
而且他们不断创新以提升性能和耐用性。所以即使是在你最艰难的出行中，你的鞋子也绝对比你更耐磨。并且它们还可以机洗。所以看起来依然像你刚买的那天一样崭新。我对此可以作证。我的那双看起来非常非常新。
I got these beautiful sort of their navy blue with like a white sole. They look really kind of chic and simple. And they're so unbelievably comfortable. They're really, really light. They form to your foot. Wool runners are built using premium supernatural materials with very low environmental impact.
今年，穿上allbirds的羊毛漫步鞋，为大自然母亲迈出巨大的一步。今天就去allbirds.com寻找你的完美鞋履吧。网址是A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S.com。好了，言归正传。所以，所以你拍了《汤米·博伊》，你拍了所有这些。然后，聊聊《白宫群英》吧，因为《白宫群英》简直是一部，
And they're constantly innovating to increase performance and longevity. So even on your toughest outings, you'll wear out long before your shoes do. And they're machine washable. So they look as fresh as the first day that you got them. And I can attest to that. Mine look very, very fresh.
我的意思是，那部剧简直，现在你依然可以看。你今天打开它看，它依然完全经得起时间的考验。太棒了。这难道不是正在引发一波回潮吗？就像，我听到人们在谈论它。我现在也经常看。是的，因为政治现在比以前更是社会生活中的一个巨大组成部分，对吧？
This year, take a big step forward for mother nature with the all birds wool runner. Discover your perfect pair at allbirds.com today. That's A-L-L-B-I-R-D-S.com. All right, back to the show. So, so you do Tommy boy, you do all this. So then you do talk about West Wing because West Wing was such a,
关于《白宫群英》很有趣的一点是，它的热度总是起起伏伏。它在热播时人们就很喜欢。然后在网飞的早期，在早期阶段，我觉得就是这部剧和《老友记》支撑起了网飞，然后它从平台上撤下了。现在不知怎么的，大家又开始迷恋它了。我不知道原因是什么，但我最近也频频听到关于它的讨论。
I mean, that show just, still you can watch it. You can turn it on today and it just completely holds up. It's so good. Isn't that kind of making a research? It's like, I hear people talking about that. I now watch it a lot. Yeah, because politics is such a big part of society now more so than then, I think, right?
不知道。所以罗布，跟我们一样，你也在做播客，你也在播客领域里耕耘。我喜欢称之为“领域”。听起来确实不错。挺不错的，对吧？我们在播客领域。这比“内容”好听多了。
It's interesting about West Wing is it kind of comes and goes. It was, people liked it when it was on. And then in the early years of Netflix, the early years, I think it was that and friends where it drove Netflix and then it went off the platform. And now something's going on that they're into it again. I don't know what it is, but I'm hearing a lot about it again too.
你应该听听我吐槽这个，罗布，我最讨厌别人说“我是一名内容创作者”。所以你就是造点他妈的垃圾呗。或者叫“故事讲述者”。如果你是个故事讲述者或者内容提供商。你喜欢做播客吗？《与罗布·洛同行》（Literally with Rob Lowe）。我太喜欢了。
I don't know. So Rob, like us, you've been doing the pod, you've been in the podcast space. I like calling it the space. It does sound good. It's good, right? We're in the podcast space. It's better than content.
我从中找到了太多乐趣，因为你知道的，这就像你们现在这样即兴发挥。你们过得很开心。你们畅所欲言。有时最琐碎的事情反而是最有趣的话题。然后你邀请嘉宾，其中很多人你可能已经认识了一辈子又一辈子，
You should hear me go off about, Rob, I hate when people go, I'm a content creator. So you just make fucking shit. Or storyteller. If you're a storyteller or content provider. Have you liked doing the podcast? Literally with Rob Lowe. I love it.
而且是以一种别人绝不可能了解他们的独特方式去认识他们，因为别人没有我和他们之间那样的历史。所以我能够挖掘出他们不为人知的一面，这是其他人做不到的，因为他们没有我跟他们共同经历的过去。而且，你知道的，我最近请到了乌比·戈德堡（Whoopi Goldberg）。当时我就说，乌比，你还记得
I have so much fun because I, you know, it's what you guys are just riffing. You're having a good time. You're saying what's on your mind. And sometimes the most trivial stuff is the most fun to talk about. And then you get guests on and a lot of them might have known forever and ever and ever
当年我们跟迈克尔·J·福克斯、简·方达、雪儿一起参加加州有毒清洁水大篷车活动吗？就在圣莫尼卡码头捡垃圾。我们还开着车去麦当劳得来速（drive-thru）买东西。你还记得吗？这种经历你去哪里找？你知道我在说什么吧？所以这真的超好玩。罗布有太多难以置信的经历，
and know them in a very specific way that no one else is ever gonna know them in the way that I do. So I'm able to bring out sides of them that no one else is gonna be able to do because they don't have the history that I have with them. And, you know, I had Whoopi Goldberg on recently. And I was like, Whoopi, do you remember
而且你有点像，我们总是拿杰森开涮，吉梅尔也喜欢拿杰森当年的那些青少年演员经历之类的故事来开涮。你们在这个圈子里有着如此漫长的经历，干过诸如此类的事情，那些奇奇怪怪的破事，你会觉得，没错，我和勒瓦尔·伯顿（Levar Burton）一起坐过10个小时的夜间火车。我知道。
when we were on the California Toxic Clean Water Caravan with Michael J. Fox, Jane Fonda, Cher. Just picking up trash down at Santa Monica Pier. And we went through the McDonald's drive-thru. Do you remember, like, where else are you gonna get that? You know what I'm saying? So it's super fun. Rob has got so many unbelievable,
我们当时正赶往维也纳去看，这他妈都是什么鬼？我知道，而且杰森跟珍妮特·杰克逊（Janet Jackson）是同学。这太疯狂了。杰森曾经跟珍妮特·杰克逊挤在同一辆按摩大巴上。这简直他妈太疯狂了。那是完全不同的另一码事，罗布。我曾经在法国南部的一艘船上看到过罗布，
and you're kind of like, and we always hammer Jason and Kimmel loves hammering Jason for stories about, you know, back when he was a teen actor and stuff. You guys have such a long history in this town of doing stuff like that, weird-ass shit, where you're like, yeah, I went on a 10-hour overnight train journey with LaVar Burton. I know.
他上来就说，我们刚刚，我们刚刚被冲走了，对吧？你被暴涨的河水或者别的什么烂七八糟的东西给冲走了。还记得吗？对，我在法国经历了一场山洪暴发并活了下来。那绝对是一场货真价实的、真正的山洪暴发。获救了。我差点被警察给营救了。
We were going on our way to Vienna to see the, like, what the fuck? I know, and that Jason went to school with Janet Jackson. It's so crazy. Jason was on the massage bus with Janet Jackson. This is like fucking crazy. That's a whole other thing, Rob. I once saw Rob on a boat in the south of France,
哦，顺便说一句，杰森，我们，我上了吉米的节目，里面有个以你的名字命名的游戏，他们现在要用我的名字来重新命名了。我只想让你知道这一点。那个游戏。真的吗？是的，就是那个游戏，你把名字写在帽子里，然后从帽子里抽出来，接着你必须根据这个名字讲一个故事。
and he comes on and goes, we were just, we just got washed out, right? You got washed out by a flooded river or some shit. Remember that? Yeah, I had survived a flash flood in France. It was like a legit, like real flash flood. Got saved. I was going to be rescued by the police.
他从帽子里抽出一个名字，或者是过去年代的某个随机名人，你必须讲一个跟此人相关的故事。哦，我敢打赌，罗布，你肯定能对答如流。哦，你绝对能对答如流。我真想让你和我一起玩那个游戏。我们应该单挑一下。为了看你们两个厮杀，我愿意付出一切。
Oh, by the way, Jason, we, so I did Jimmy's show, and there's a game that's named after you that they're now renaming after me. I just want you to know. The game. Really? Yes, it's, so it's the game where you put the names in the hat, and then you pull the hat out, and then you have to tell a story about the name.
我们现在就玩一个版本吧。我为你挑个名字，然后你为我挑一个。这主意真棒。好吧，准备好了吗？这主意真棒。好吧，我准备好了。这很有趣。好的。
He pulls a name out of a hat, or some random celebrity from years past, and you have to tell a story associated with it. Oh, I bet Rob, Rob, you must crush that. Oh, you must crush that. I want you and I to play that game. We should go mono a mono. I would give anything to watch you two fucking go on that.
特利·萨瓦拉斯（Telly Savalas）。我和他没有任何直接互动，但我相信我妻子的话，他可能是我的教父，或者不，他也可能是詹妮弗·安妮斯顿的教父。我想，我……我想他是珍的教父，对吧？我想他是珍的教父，
Let's just play a version right now. I'll pick a name for you, and then you pick a name for me. That's a great idea. Okay, ready? That's a great idea. Okay, I'm ready. It's fun. Okay.
而且阿曼达和她关系极其要好，所以这就是为什么……这相当不错。所以这也算是沾亲带故，这让我想起了我的新建筑公司。它叫“毗邻减排”（Adjacent Abatement），我们的业务就是进去清除……好啦，这是我为你准备的。皮娅·扎多拉（Pia Zadora）。
Telly Savalas. I don't have any direct interaction with him, but I believe my wife that that my, or no, he may be her godfather, or maybe he's the godfather of Jen Aniston. I think, I... I think he's Jen's godfather, right? I think he's Jen's godfather,
嗯，好吧，可以。你有一个？所以当时我正在海滩边跟格利高里·派克（Gregory Peck）的女儿亲热。他妈的，哦天哪。去他的。都闭嘴，继续说，罗布。然后我听到有个女人在喊：这太令人作呕了。
and Amanda and she are so close, so that's why it's... That's pretty good. So it's sort of, it's adjacent too, which reminds me of my new construction company. It's called Adjacent Abatement, and what we do is we go in and we take mold out from... All right, here's my one for you. Pia Zadora.
你们应该为自己感到羞耻。难道你们一点起码的体面都没有吗？这个海滩上还有小孩子呢。我抬头一看，居然是皮娅·扎多拉。这太疯狂了。不过作为额外加分项，我们居然能把格利高里·派克的女儿和马里布海滩（Malibu Colony）扯上关系。我的意思是，罗布，这老兄简直是王室成员。
Mm, yeah, okay. You have one? So I was making out on the Colony Beach with Gregory Peck's daughter. Fucking, oh my God. Fucking it. Everybody shut up, keep going, Rob. And I hear this woman going, that's disgusting.
你是个英雄。行啦。罗布，我的天呐，你认识唐尼（Downey）多久了？九年级历史课。哇，在马里布那边？圣莫尼卡高中（Samohi，Santa Monica High School）。哇。我能想象得到。
You should be ashamed of yourself. Don't you have any common decency? There are children on this beach. And I looked up and it was Pia Zadora. That's crazy. But how about for bonus points, we get Gregory Peck's daughter and the Malibu Colony. I mean, Rob, this man is royalty.
我记得在圣诞节的时候，我在圣诞派对上看到你，然后我看到你跟罗布还有唐尼聊天，当时我就想：我一眼就能看出，噢，这是深交。这是深厚、长久、极深极深的交情。你们之间有着那种自小相识的默契。是的。
You're a hero. Come on. Rob, Jesus Christ, how long have you known Downey? Ninth grade history class. Wow, out there in Malibu? Sam Ohai, Santa Monica High School. Wow. I could see it.
你真是个英雄。得了吧。罗布，天哪，你认识唐尼多久了？九年级历史课。哇，在马里布那边？山姆·奥海，圣莫尼卡高中。哇。我能看出来。
I remember at Christmas when I saw you at the Christmas party and then I saw you talk to Rob and to Downey and I was like, I could immediately see like, oh, this is deep. This is deep, long, deep, deep. You guys have that shorthand of knowing each other since being kids. Yeah.
我记得在圣诞派对上看到你，然后看到你和罗布还有唐尼说话，当时我就觉得，我一眼就能看出，噢，这交情很深。这是那种深厚、长久、非常深厚的交情。你们有一种从小就认识的默契。是的。
That was so... And there was no one more fun to party with. Downey made me laugh harder than any human being in the world. And I just love what he's done with his life and he's such an inspiration and a great guy. And by the way, Downey was on the bus with Sharon and Whoopi Goldberg as well.
太……而且没人比他更会办派对。小唐尼让我笑得比世上任何人都开心。我真的很喜欢他对自己人生的经营，他太励志了，是个绝佳的家伙。顺便说一句，小唐尼当时也和莎伦以及乌比·戈德堡在车上。
I mean, he was, we were always doing that stuff. My mom used to call her Whoopi. Well, because in her defense, she couldn't see the whole word because the W was covered. Because that's where the I, the bus. But can't see the bus. And Rob, do you think you'd be able to recall enough
我是说，他，我们总是在干那种事。我妈以前管她叫乌比。好吧，为她辩解一下，她看不清整个词，因为W被挡住了。因为那是，公交车。但看不见公交车。罗布，你觉得你能回忆起足够多的内容
to write a satisfying book? He's written a book. Sorry, let me finish. And he's toward it very successfully. But in a book, when I say book, I mean a follow-up, a series. Yes, yes. What's it called?
来写一本令人满意的书吗？他写过书。抱歉，让我说完。他为此做了非常成功的巡回宣传。但在一本书中，当我说书时，我指的是后续作品，一个系列。是的，是的。它叫什么名字？
Stories I Only Tell My Friends, is that right? Stories I Only Tell My Friends and the follow-up, Love Life. So we were talking about... So I'm talking about the third one. The third one, the third one is called Names and Dates. And it's just Names and Dates and what the fuck has happened? Gregory Peck's daughter, March 12th.
《我只告诉朋友的故事》，对吗？《我只告诉朋友的故事》以及后续的《爱生活》。所以我们在谈论……所以我在谈论第三本。第三本，第三本叫《名字与日期》。里面全都是名字与日期，这到底发生了什么？格利高里·派克的女儿，3月12日。
It is Adora, you know, the fucking... So now, Rob, and now you're back. I know that your new thing, well, not new, but you're obsessed with golf. You've been playing a lot. You and I played a couple of months ago with Danny D's, by the way, Rob's good buddies with Danny, who's a friend of the program.
是阿多拉，你知道的，他妈的……所以现在，罗布，你回来了。我知道你的新爱好，呃，也不是新爱好，但你迷上了高尔夫。你一直在频繁打球。你和我几个月前还和丹尼·D一起打过球，顺便说一句，罗布和丹尼关系很好，丹尼是节目的老朋友。
Yeah, he's the best. He's the best. He's the world's only good finance guy. And how you were talking about how obsessed you are with and your game is getting really good. I mean, you're just getting there. You're on it, right? Like you're practicing a lot.
对，他是最棒的。他是最棒的。他是世上唯一的优秀金融男。你之前说你有多着迷，而且你的球技变得越来越好。我的意思是，你渐入佳境了。你很上心，对吧？就像你经常练习一样。
Oh, I practice all the time. I don't get to play as much because I don't have that much time really, but I'm practicing easily four days a week. Like today, I'm at Fox. Is there a goal? Yes, yes. My goal is to do what you did.
哦，我一直在练习。我没法经常下场打，因为我确实没那么多时间，但我绝对能保证一周练四天。比如今天，我在福克斯球场。有个目标吗？是的，是的。我的目标是做你做过的事。
I want to play in the AT&T. How was that for you? That was incredible. I mean, we'll almost won the damn thing, but I had a really good time myself too. And all you got to do is just put your hand up. They'll have you up there. I mean...
我想去打AT&T圆石滩职业业余配对赛。你当时感觉怎么样？那太棒了。我是说，我们差点就赢了那该死的比赛，但我自己也玩得非常开心。你只需要举起手来。他们就会让你去。我是说……
Rob, you're in. You're in for next year with us. Come on. It was such a blast. It was amazing. I'm doing, guys, I'm doing it. I'm 100% doing it. It always falls right in the middle
罗布，你入选了。明年你和我们一起。来吧。太好玩了。太神奇了。伙计们，我要去，我100%要去。比赛总是刚好落在
of the production schedule, but I'm actually going to ask for the time off next year. And I'm absolutely committing to doing it. There you go. I got to follow Tiger inside the ropes at Genesis. And yeah, I got to be inside the ropes with Tiger, Rory, and JT. It was insane.
制作日程的中间，但我明年真的要请假。我绝对承诺要参加。那就对了。我在捷恩斯邀请赛上跟着泰格走在绳圈里面。没错，我和泰格、麦克罗伊以及贾斯汀·托马斯一起走在绳圈里面。太疯狂了。
Wow. Oh yeah, those rounds were incredible. Were you there the day when Tiger birdied the last three holes and they all birdied 18 together? No, that was the day after. I was there the day that he almost had the hole and won. Yeah.
哇。哦，对，那些轮次的比赛太精彩了。泰格在最后三个洞抓鸟，他们一起在18号洞抓鸟的那天你在现场吗？不，那是第二天。我在他差点一杆进洞并获胜的那天在现场。对。
Oh, that was incredible. Yeah. One revolution. But I also saw him, you know the green with the sand trap in the middle of it? Oh, yeah, totally. You saw him putt into the sand trap. Yes.
哦，那太不可思议了。对。只差一圈。但我也看到他了，你知道中间有沙坑果岭的那个洞吗？哦，对，完全知道。你看到他把球推击进沙坑里了。是的。
Did you see that? I saw Tiger Woods putt into the sand trap, which just to me was the most beautiful thing in the world because I'm like, okay, that's the greatest who ever hoisted a golf club. Yeah, and even he can do that. And even it was the thing was he was going to take his medicine.
你看到了吗？我看到泰格·伍兹把球推击进沙坑，对我来说，这简直是世界上最美妙的事情，因为我想，好吧，那是挥舞过高尔夫球杆的最伟大的人。是的，连他也会那样。而且当时的情况是，他得接受现实。
He was going to, you know, it's that thing we always do where we can't quite bring ourselves to take our medicine. We kind of also want to do the, he kind of, and he did get up and down before though. He did, but I've putted into that bunker twice. Yep. In my life.
他得，你知道的，这就是我们常做的事：我们总是无法说服自己去接受现实。我们某种程度上还想去做那个，他某种程度上，不过他之前确实救球成功了。他确实做到了，但我有两次把球推击进那个沙坑。是的。在我的一生中。
So. I bet he didn't make four. Twice. And the other thing he did that I noticed was whenever he would do something like that, he would go to another gear in whatever the next hole was. Like another gear.
所以。我敢打赌他没打出4杆。两次。他做的另一件我注意到的是，每当他做类似的事情时，他在接下来的任何一个洞都会切换到另一个档位。就像另一个档位。
I want to get Tiger on this show. I know, it'd be great to have him on. Me too. I'm wild. God, I just, Rob, I could just listen to you talk about all your stuff, all your. I know, I love. God, it's just everything.
我想请泰格上这个节目。我知道，请他来一定很棒。我也是。我太激动了。天哪，罗布，我真能一直听你讲你的那些事，你的那些……我知道，我喜欢。天哪，真的是所有事。
Whether it's his movies or his shows or his life. By the way, well, this is what the podcast is. I mean, because a lot of times somebody will bring up something and I'll go, that reminds me, because I do have a telecivilous story where I was eight years old and Kojak was coming to date in Ohio to sign autographs
不管是他的电影、他的节目还是他的生活。顺便说一句，这就是这个播客的节目形式。我的意思是，很多时候某人会提起一件事，然后我就会说，这让我想起了……因为我确实有一个关于小电视的搞笑故事，当时我八岁，泰利·萨瓦拉斯要来到俄亥俄州代顿的雷克斯百货公司，
from the ladies undergarments of Reich's department store. Oh my God. Is that true? It was, yeah, absolutely true. And so I got my bus fare together. On the graphic underwear on the third floor is Telly Savalas. Yeah, yeah.
为女士内衣柜台签名。天哪。真的吗？是的，绝对千真万确。所以我凑够了车资。在三楼的印花内衣区有泰利·萨瓦拉斯。对，对。
And he was probably doing a Kenley Players. It was probably Telly Savalas and, you know, some Arthur Miller show. And I take the bus and I wait in line forever. And I bought him a sucker. Cause I know Telly Savalas likes, remember Kojak always had the sucker? Yeah.
他当时可能在演《肯利演员剧团》。可能是一部泰利·萨瓦拉斯和，你知道的，某种阿瑟·米勒的剧。我坐公交车去排了很久的队。我给他买了一根棒棒糖。因为我知道泰利·萨瓦拉斯喜欢，还记得科贾克总是拿着棒棒糖吗？对。
Yeah. He always had up like a Charms blow pop. That was his thing. And so I bought him one and I brought it and I was going to give it to him. And it's a three and a half hour line. And I'm waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting. I finally get right to the front of the line
对。他总是拿着像夏氏棒棒糖那样的糖。那是他的标志。所以我给他买了一根，我带了过去，打算送给他。队伍排了三个半小时。我等了又等，等了又等。我终于排到了队伍最前面，
and they go, that's it. Mr. Savalas has to leave. And he fucking bails. And I'm standing here with my sucker. And I kind of looked for somebody I think is important. And I go, excuse me, would you give Mr. Savalas my sucker? And he goes, oh kid, that's so thoughtful.
然后他们说，就这样了。萨瓦拉斯先生必须得走了。他他妈的溜了。我站在那儿手里拿着棒棒糖。我环顾四周，寻找一个我认为重要的人，我说，对不起，你能把我的棒棒糖交给萨瓦拉斯先生吗？然后他说，哦，孩子，你太贴心了。
I sure will. And I walk away and I'm going down the escalator. I turn around to watch and the guy throws it in the trash can. Oh. That's awful. That actually stayed with me forever. Because whenever, like I meet someone, I'm always like, don't be Telly Savalas.
我一定会的。然后我走开了，走在自动扶梯上。我转过身去看着，那家伙直接把它扔进垃圾桶了。哦。太糟糕了。这事真的让我记了一辈子。因为每当我遇到什么人，我总是会想：别像泰利·萨瓦拉斯那样。
Don't throw it in the sun, don't be. Right, right, right. And they give you a bag of freshly cooked homemade cookies. And you're like, no, I'm going to eat these. In fairness, it wasn't Telly who did it, it was a guy. It was a handler. It's true. Right, handler.
别把它扔进，别那样。对，对，对。他们会给你一袋刚烤好的自制曲奇饼干。然后你会想，不，我要吃掉这些。公平地说，不是泰利干的，是一个工作人员。是个经纪人。确实。没错，经纪人。
It wasn't Telly, he probably would have taken it. Telly would have sucked it, for sure. No, he probably would have sucked it. Wait, there's a better way to say it. He's thrown it at you. Well, I wouldn't, I want to listen. I haven't listened, I don't, I'm not really into podcasts, so.
不是泰利，他很可能会收下的。泰利肯定会把它含在嘴里的。不，他很可能会含着的。等等，有更好的说法。他把它朝你扔了过来。好吧，我不会，我想听。我没听过，我不太懂，我其实不太听播客，所以。
Well, you make a hit podcast. You don't need to listen to another one. I get it. It's a radio show. To Will, he's doing radio. It is radio. It's morning zoo. I feel like it's morning zoo.
好吧，你制作了一个热门播客。你不需要听别的。我懂。这是一个广播节目。对威尔来说，他在做广播。这就是广播。这是晨间动物园节目。我觉得这就是晨间动物园节目。
Drive time. Yeah, drive time. I'm always, I'm just trying to copy my buddy, Johnny Vaughn over there in the UK. And Rob, you're a helicopter pilot. How's the traffic on the five? Yeah. You know, it's looking a little backed up over here
早高峰节目。对，早高峰。我一直在，我只是想效仿我的老友约翰·沃恩，他在英国那边。罗布，你是直升机驾驶员。5号公路的交通情况怎么样？对。你知道的，那边看起来有点拥堵，
as the pole would have passed. It's pale lights as far as you can see. We got the uniform for it. Well, Rob, let's get out again. Let's get out and play again. It's really fun. I want to be a part of that as soon as my granddad backheels up.
正如电线杆经过时那样。远望过去一片车灯。我们为此穿上了制服。好吧，罗布，让我们再出去。让我们再出去打球。真的很有趣。只要我爷爷的腿好利索了，我也想参与其中。
Yeah, that's not good, man. No, I know. Don't come back too soon. I know. I got a date coming up in two days. I got to have a nice- Are you doing ice baths? You got a date in two days and it made us cool with that? She's just like- She wants me to be smart and safe
是的，那可不太妙，伙计。不，我知道。别太早复出。我知道。我两天后有个约会。我得有一个漂亮的——你在做冰浴吗？你两天后有个约会，她能接受这个吗？她就像——她希望我明智点、安全点，
and she's letting me make my own decision, which is nice. And so- So she doesn't mind that you're, are you both dating or is it just you? I am icing it. That does seem to help. Good, yeah. I'd tell you one of the nicest thing. And this is a true story.
她让我自己做决定，这很好。所以——所以她不介意你，你们俩都在约会还是只有你？我在做冰敷。这似乎确实有帮助。很好，对。我告诉你一件最暖心的事。这是个真实的故事。
This is not a bit. I hurt my back a couple of years ago now. And I was at, and I texted J.B. I was like, my back really hurts. Anyway, I was at home and all of a sudden, out of nowhere, into my backyard comes Jason. And he's got like a back heating thing and like an icy hot thing and a bunch of stuff
这不是段子。我几年前背受伤了。当时我在，我给JB发了信息，我说我背疼得厉害。不管怎样，当时我在家，突然之间，毫无征兆地，杰森来到了我的后院。他带了一个背部加热垫、一个冰热理疗贴还有一堆东西，
that he brought for my back. I just dropped it off and then I got back to my hard left. And he came into my backyard. I was in the sauna and he came in and he knocked on me. He's like, I got all this stuff. I was like- Just like a little angel. And then he got back in his car and left. That's right.
都是他给我背部准备的。放下就走了，然后我就回到了我左边。他走进我的后院。当时我在桑拿房里，他走进来敲门。他说，我带了这些东西。我说——就像个小天使一样。然后他上车就走了。没错。
Once a year. Yeah. Once, yeah, even a stop clock. I thought even a stopped clock, you know? Tells the right time twice a day. Okay, listen, Rob, we love you, man. I'm so excited about your show with John and he's such a nice kid.
一年一次。对。有一次，对，哪怕是停着的时钟。我以为哪怕是停着的时钟，你知道的？一天也能报对两次时间。好吧，听着，罗布，我们爱你，伙计。我太期待你和约翰的节目了，他是个如此好的孩子。
Please say hi to him before me. Yeah. And also say hi to Cheryl. And to Cheryl, your lovely wife of many years. So sweet, God, you guys are such nice peeps and couldn't happen to a better dude. I love you guys. I was so excited.
请替我向他问好。对。也替我向谢丽尔问好。还有谢丽尔，你多年来可爱的妻子。太甜了，天哪，你们俩真是太好的人了，没有比这更好的家伙了。我爱你们。我太激动了。
You're three of my favorite in all series is three of my favorite people. I love everything about you guys. I love hanging with you. I love your work. I love your podcast. Dude, Bateman, you're making me laugh right now. So hard in the fucking trailer for the Air Jordan movie.
你们三个是我最喜欢的，在所有系列里你们三个是我最喜欢的人。我爱你们的一切。我喜欢和你们在一起。我喜欢你们的工作。我喜欢你们的播客。伙计，贝特曼，你现在把我逗笑了。在《气垫传奇》的预告片里笑得那么大声。
I know. It's like only you can fucking steal a trailer with one life. Yeah, I know. It's so great. It's so great. Nice. It's amazing.
我知道。就好像只有你才能用一句台词抢走预告片的光彩。对，我知道。太棒了。太棒了。真好。太惊艳了。
It's amazing. It's amazing. Love you, miss you, mean it. Yeah. Love you, miss you, mean it. Santa Barbara will go and hang or in the, let's make it happen. Or just get fired off one of these 10,000 jobs you're doing
太惊艳了。太惊艳了。爱你，想你，真心实意的。对。爱你，想你，真心实意的。我们去圣巴巴拉聚聚，或者在，让它成真吧。或者干脆从你正在做的这一万个工作里被解雇一个，
and free some time up and let's go hang out. I know. It has to be the weekends. It's not working so hard. All right. It has to be the weekends. Thank you, the great Rob Lowe. We love you, buddy.
腾出点时间，我们一起去闲逛吧。我知道。必须是周末。工作不能这么忙。好吧。必须是周末。谢谢伟大的罗布·洛。我们爱你，伙计。
I love you. It's low in your chin. It's load. Load. Oh, Rob Lowe. Don't forget, podcast. Rob Lowe, literally. Wherever you get your podcasts.
我爱你。是Low在你的下巴。是Load。Load。哦，罗布·洛（Rob Lowe）。别忘了，播客。罗布·洛，字面意义。无论你在哪听播客。
Literally with Rob Lowe. Listen to Rob's podcast. Listen to Rob's podcast. And unstable on Netflix. You're watching it. You're loving it. Everything Rob Lowe'd all the time. Love you, boys.
《字面意义上的罗布·洛》。听罗布的播客。听罗布的播客。还有Netflix上的《不稳定》。你在看。你很喜欢。全都是罗布·洛，随时随地。爱你们，男孩们。
Love you, buddy. Thanks for doing this, Rob. Bye, buddy. Bye. Lovely man. That Rob Lowe. That Rob Lowe, he's just always been nice, always been talented, always been handsome.
爱你，伙计。谢谢你做这些，罗布。再见，伙计。再见。可爱的人。那个罗布·洛。那个罗布·洛，他一直都很好，一直很有才华，一直很帅。
Yeah. That's another guy I'd like to come back as. I think there's a long list here of guests we've had that I'd like to. Yeah. You can talk to him for hours. We re-encarnated him. We tried to get him on.
对。这也是另一个我想转世变成的人。我觉得我们这儿有过长长的一串嘉宾名单，我都想……对。你可以和他聊上几个小时。我们让他转世了。我们试图请他来。
I tried to get him on before. He was the one we had technical glitch a couple of weeks ago. And we had to dial. That was Rob. Yes. Oh, that was Rob. Oh, I didn't know. So I've been trying to get him on here forever.
我以前就试过请他来。他是几个星期前我们出现技术故障的那个人。我们得重新拨号。那是罗布。是的。哦，那是罗布。哦，我不知道。所以我一直在试着请他上节目。
You know, we had a technical glitch with McConaughey way back when, right? When are you going to rebook him? I don't know. I want to get it back on here. That was great. Because when we do have McConaughey on, then we can go through, hopefully we have the recording
你知道的，很久以前我们和麦康纳也遇到过技术故障，对吧？你打算什么时候重新预约他？我不知道。我想让他再来。那次很棒。因为当我们请来麦康纳时，我们就可以复盘——希望我们有那段录音——
of me having my hissy fit. When you had your... Didn't I snap at him a little bit? Didn't I tell him? You did. Your laughing is not making things helpful. Yeah. Surprise guests.
记录下我大发脾气的样子。当你——我是不是对他有点发脾气？我是不是告诉他——你确实发了。你的笑并没有帮上什么忙。对。惊喜嘉宾。
And then you... And then you slammed. Who was laughing? And you slammed your... Yeah, that was so great. And then, and we can talk about contact. And we can talk about contact. You know, but I did, it didn't occur to me.
然后你——然后你猛地。谁在笑？然后你猛地——是的，那太棒了。然后，我们可以聊聊《超时空接触》。我们可以聊聊《超时空接触》。你知道，但我当时没想到。
You're going to fucking break me today, Sean, with the contact change. It occurred to me earlier. Like it is somewhat, it's either dangerous or good or whatever about this thing. Is that we do this all the time. We're always just sort of just, you know, almost every day we're picking up the,
肖恩，你今天换隐形眼镜的事简直要把我搞崩溃了。我之前就想到了。这事有点——对这事本身的看法要么是危险的，要么是好的，或者别的什么。就是我们一直在做这件事。我们总是，差不多每天都在拿起电话，
we're talking with one another. No matter what mood we're in, and we drag that into these interviews, these conversations for the public. And oftentimes we're doing this thing in a bad mood. And like, what if we like, what if we get in a fight with one another? I mean, I know it's been, it's been tense a couple of times,
我们在互相交谈。不管我们心情如何，我们都会把这种情绪带进这些采访中，带进这些面向公众的对话中。很多时候我们是在心情不好的时候做这件事。比如，如果我们——如果我们吵架了怎么办？我的意思是，我知道之前有几次气氛确实挺紧张的，
but like, people just get like warts and all on this. And is that smart for us to be doing that? Why not? It's real, it's normal. It's real, I guess, yeah. Also, who cares? Who cares? We're not gonna get in a fight.
但人们在节目里展现得淋漓尽致。我们这么做明智吗？为什么不呢？这是真实的，是正常的。是真的，我想，是的。再说，谁在乎呢？谁在乎呢？我们又不会打起来。
Like what's the worst mood number? Fuck you, Sean. Fuck you. Don't you disagree with what I'm sick? We've had, I think it's, I don't know. I just think like who, I really mean it when I say who cares. I mean, we might as well, right?
最差的心情是怎样的？去你的，肖恩。去你的。难道你不同意我的看法吗？我们有过，我觉得这——我只是觉得谁，我是说“谁在乎”的时候是认真的。我的意思是，我们不妨就这样，对吧？
Cause it's gonna be lights out at some point. And then. Anyway, Rob Lowe, you know- Love Rob Lowe. Love Rob, huh? This Rob Lowe. Hey, you know, Rob was in contact. He was in contact.
因为总有一天要熄灯谢幕。然后。不管怎样，罗布·洛，你知道的——爱罗布·洛。爱罗布，哈？这个罗布·洛。嘿，你知道，罗布演过《超时空接触》。他演过。
He was. He was in contact. And by the way, he's not, he's not allergic to work. Boy, he works a lot. By the way, just for the record, no recollection of him in contact or Matthew McConaughey for that matter. Well, Matthew McConaughey and Johnny Foster
他演过。他演过《超时空接触》。顺便说一句，他可不排斥工作。天哪，他工作真多。顺便说一句，有一说一，我完全不记得他演过《超时空接触》，马修·麦康纳也是。好吧，马修·麦康纳和朱迪·福斯特
were the stars. Yeah, yeah. But I only remember her in it. And wasn't there a kid too? No? There were no kid. Oh. I'm conflating.
是主角。对，对。但我只记得她在里面。里面是不是还有一个小孩？没有吗？没有小孩。哦。我记混了。
You thinking of Nell? Another Jody Foster vehicle. I do remember the incredible opening pullback, right? From Earth, but all the way back. Oh, and I emailed you that one shot where she runs into the mirror. Into the mirror, yep. How'd they do it?
你想的是《大地的女儿》？朱迪·福斯特的另一部电影。我确实记得那个惊人的开场镜头，对吧？从地球一直拉远。哦，我给你发过那个她跑进镜子的镜头。跑进镜子里，对。他们是怎么拍的？
Still don't know how to do it. Oh, that's how they, that's the kid when she was a little kid. Yes, thank you. Thank you. But wait, but in his show that he's doing now, the 9-1-1 Lone Star, I couldn't tell if he was a cop or a CIA or an F.
到现在都不知道怎么拍的。哦，那是他们，那是她小时候的那个孩子。对，谢谢。谢谢。但是等等，但在他现在演的那部剧《紧急呼救：孤星》里，我分不清他到底是警察、中情局还是联邦
B. Y. Right? Go high, go high, go high. We'll allow, and repeat it, and repeat it, and repeat it. I love it. I love it a lot. Smart.
调查局的人。对吧？走高，走高，走高。我们允许，然后重复，重复，重复。我喜欢。我非常喜欢。精明。
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barberco. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts,
精炼。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔贾尔夫和本尼特·巴尔伯科100%有机纯手工打造。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客都能收听，
or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者你也可以现在就在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Wondery App上订阅Wondery Plus来提前收听无广告版。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。